muy buenas noches y gracias por
continuar con nosotros en francia 24
bienvenidos a este especial de noticias
donde a partir de este momento vamos a
llevarles todo el cubrimiento de la
convención nacional del partido
demócrata que comienza hoy 17 de agosto
y va hasta el próximo jueves 20 durante
estos 4 días usted podrá sintonizar
nuestro canal a partir de las 20 horas
de bogotá quito lima donde les
llevaremos un completo análisis de la
política estadounidense con invitados y
nuestros corresponsales en las ciudades
más importantes de ese país este año
debido a la pandemia de coronavirus la
convención del partido se realizará de
manera virtual por primera vez en la
historia y cuya temática central será la
unidad del país en ella se espera que el
ex vicepresidente de la administración
de barack obama joe biden junto a su
fórmula vicepresidencial cama las aves
sean oficialmente nominados como los
candidatos del partido a la presidencia
y vicepresidencia en esta primera
jornada se esperan las intervenciones y
oradores como el senador por vermont
bernie sanders el gobernador de nuevo
andrew cuomo y la ex primera dama
michelle obama se espera también las
palabras de un republicano el ex
gobernador del estado de ohio john
kasich un representante emblemático del
movimiento anti trump que existe dentro
de esa ala conservadora con su
intervención se espera a llegar a un
grupo de votantes que bailen quiere
conquistar de cara a estas elecciones
del 3 de noviembre una contienda
política también atípica marcada por un
vaivén que llega fortalecido unas
encuestas y que promete restaurar el
alma de la nación la nominación de la
primera mujer afroamericana a la
vicepresidencia una pandemia que deja ya
más de 170 mil muertos en el país una
economía de caída que deja millones de
desempleos y un vasto movimiento de
descontento social que pide el fin del
racismo sistemático en el país una más
reciente polémica que gira en torno a la
votación por correo que según trump es
un vehículo para que se presente el
fraude electoral todos estos puntos los
vamos a analizar con nuestros
corresponsales más mensajes desde la
ciudad de nueva york y diana castañeda
desde la capital está
washington dice precisamente me quiero
ir hasta la capital de eeuu con nuestra
corresponsal diana diana muy buena noche
para usted comienzo preguntándole qué
esperar de esta convención atípica que
además por primera vez se hace de manera
virtual debido a esta pandemia de
coronavirus que golpea fuertemente a
eeuu
bueno pues básicamente lo que vamos a
ver es como los demócratas van aa
mostrar el panorama la crisis que está
enfrentando el país hoy en día por el
coronavirus y lo que ha causado la falta
de liderazgo del presidente de donald
trump como es el caso de la crisis
económica más profunda 40 millones de
personas desempleadas que han solicitado
subsidios la crisis en materia de salud
al igual que los pequeños negocios que
no logran salir adelante en medio de
estas múltiples normas que se están
tomando pero también en lo que van a
tratar de mostrar los demócratas es que
la fórmula byd en el país es esa fórmula
que se necesita para sacar adelante el
país y también haciendo un llamado a la
unidad dentro del propio partido
demócrata y a movilizar a todos los
demócratas a las urnas otro de los temas
centrales que veremos es la justicia
racial porque no solo ha sido un año que
se ha visto digamos afectado
eeuu por la pandemia pero también por
las múltiples protestas después de la
muerte del hombre afroamericano george
flow en manos de policías blancos que
digamos despertado un momento para que
se aborde el tema de la justicia racial
y por supuesto también veremos incluso
una de las sorpresas de esta convención
es como los demócratas han logrado traer
a figuras importantes del partido
republicano para que hagan un llamado a
los republicanos a que se unan a las
filas del partido demócrata estamos
hablando de crisis que viene era
candidato también a la presidencia y
quién era una de las personas más
visibles de este partido y que estará
hablando de cómo el presidente trono
representa los valores del partido y
hará un llamado a esos republicanos para
que se unan a los demócratas por
supuesto veremos las principales figuras
más destacadas no solo a nivel nacional
sino también gobernadores
el local y estatal que harán parte de
estos de cuatro días en donde los
demócratas tienen toda la atención del
país así es bien usted nos acaba de
decir entonces todo el amplio panorama
de estas elecciones y lo que vamos a ver
también en estos cuatro días de esta
convención demócrata que se está
llevando a cabo en este momento y quiero
ir de washington a la ciudad de nueva
york otro punto importante en ese país
por todo lo que está pasando además por
la pandemia de kobe 19 que es un punto a
tratar en esta convención demócrata de
cuatro días allá se encuentra en nuestra
corresponsal mamá en sala mamen buena
noche para usted vamos a hablar un poco
también de la virtualidad que se está
presentando en este momento en esta
convención cuál es el ambiente en la
ciudad de nueva york y además le quiero
preguntar si esta convención de manera
virtual despierta el mismo interés en
los votantes y la población
sí muy buenas noches eso es lo que vamos
a poder ver estos cuatro días si
realmente todo el esfuerzo que están
haciendo los demócratas en esta
convención pues sin parangón en esta
convención histórica por la situación
pandémica la que nos encontramos va
realmente dar los frutos que ellos
esperan que es la movilización de esos
votantes para que vayan a las urnas este
3 de noviembre es importante también
referente a esto que comentaba sobre la
pandemia que precisamente es uno de los
temas importantes y por el que abogan
los demócratas que donald tram no ha
sido capaz de gestionar correctamente
esta pandemia y por eso precisamente
esta noche escucharemos a una de las
figuras que ha resaltado más en estos
cinco meses que ha sido el gobernador de
nueva york andrew cuomo un demócrata que
ha destacado por su gestión en la ciudad
de nueva york que comenzó siendo el
epicentro de esta pandemia y a día de
hoy pues va en cuarta posición bajando
poco a poco en cuanto a los estados que
están más castigados por otras de
florida california y de texas esto es
algo se está haciendo bien aquí y andrew
como vendrá esta noche un poquito a
defender
es importante que aprendamos las
lecciones que hemos visto durante esta
pandemia que nos ha separado pero que
también nos tiene que servir para
aprender que es importante tener un
dirigente que nos sepa digamos conducir
al país hacia lo que realmente estamos
buscando la verdad que va a ser una
noche muy emocionante y no solamente por
lo que vamos a poder ver sino por ver
cómo se va a desarrollar está este
experimento de alguna manera porque han
sido los de montás los primeros que van
a tener que hacer esta convención
virtual y la semana que viene los
republicanos jugarán ya con un poquito
de ventaja después de lo que ha ocurrido
durante esta semana durante todo el día
hemos ido viendo diferentes caucus por
la mujer por los latinos ha sido
interesante porque sí que es verdad que
hemos visto algún que otro fallo técnico
que es otro de los problemas de los
miedos que hay también ver cómo se
desarrolla no va a haber aplausos no va
a haber abucheos entonces pues bueno a
ver si no se hace un poquito pesado
estas dos horas de pues al final de
escuchar un discurso detrás de otro y
sin un poco la participación del público
que al final es lo que le da también
a este tipo de congresos y respecto a
eso que usted está diciendo mamen hay
discursos pregrabados prácticamente
todos los discursos ya fueron grabados
con anterioridad y le digo que si eso
hará entonces un poco las intervenciones
más frías
claro precisamente eso es lo que les
preocupa el hecho de que un discurso
detrás de otro pueda llevar a que los
votantes pues al final acaben apagando
sus televisores o sus o sus teléfonos de
sus ipads no sí que es verdad que la
mayoría de los discursos están grabados
sabemos que él es candidato bernie
sanders por ejemplo se va a lanzar a
hacerlo en vivo tendrá por supuesto un
plan b por si hay algún fallo técnico
pero la mayoría de los conferenciantes
que veremos hoy de los ponentes que
veremos sois lo van a hacer grabados por
eso hemos podido ver algunos extractos
por ejemplo del discurso de michelle
obama hemos podido ver también algunos
extractos del discurso del gobernador
andrew cuomo y veremos a ver cómo se
desarrollan entre uno y otro podremos
ver momentos que intentarán romper con
esa monotonía pero desde luego no va a
ser nada fácil teniendo en cuenta que
bueno que todos los estadounidenses lo
van a ver desde los salones de su casa
mamen gracias por la información ya
vuelvo con usted y también con nuestra
corresponsal en washington dice diana
castañeda porque llegó el momento
entonces de presentar a dos
los invitados que nos van a estar
acompañando durante estas horas de
especial para analizar como lo
comentábamos anteriormente esta
convención demócrata de cara a las
elecciones presidenciales del 3 de
noviembre en eeuu quiero comenzar
entonces presentando a la señora
maricruz mcgowan ella es estratega
republicana economista y vocera del
comité nacional republicano ya nos
atiende muy amablemente desde también la
capital estadounidense washington dice y
por otro lado también nos acompaña el
señor robert valència analista político
internacional desde la ciudad de nueva
york muchísimas gracias por atender
nuestro llamado para analizar lo que
ocurre entonces en eeuu quiero empezar
con el señor robert valència analizando
un poco el contexto político y social de
cómo llega a eeuu a esta primera
convención demócrata en el país
bueno indudablemente es lo que ya hemos
escuchado de este es una convención
sugerido buenas noches a ustedes muy
buenas noches a todos los que nos están
viendo en esta noche tan importante en
el contexto en el que nos encontramos
actualmente es por esto que esto es una
elección
indudablemente relevante en medio de
muchos bemoles como sabemos
el país está en vilo porque no sabemos
qué va a pasar con los votos que se van
a emitir por medio del correo se ha
hablado de algún tipo de fraude como lo
ha señalado el presidente de donald
trump pero también los demócratas han
mostrado su asombro y no en el sentido
positivo sino que el hecho de que muchos
de estos buzones han sido retirados de
las calles y obviamente estoy encendido
las alarmas porque muchos lo consideran
como una afrenta a la democracia y
seguro vamos a escuchar esa
ese acontecimiento es lo que está
ocurriendo ese desarrollo en el
transcurso de esta semana y veremos
vamos a ver de qué de qué está hecho de
qué está hecha está esta llave demócrata
y compuesta por joe biden y quemada here
is que aunque han avivado por por
supuesto las y las emociones dentro del
partido demócrata y esto se vio
reflejado en él en la cantidad de dinero
que incluso ellos recogieron en el
momento que se anunció la cámara here it
como la compañera de campaña para yo
bailé así que vamos a ver
qué es lo que va a proponer el
presidente y el vicepresidente yo vaya
actualmente con cámara xerez y esto es
lo que analizaremos vamos a ver cómo los
latinos se ven reflejado en lo que ellos
vayan a proponer el tema de la justicia
criminal que es uno de los el talón de
aquiles para que managers y paraguay den
el tema de la economía porque como lo
mencionamos lamentablemente muchas
personas han perdido sus empleos y
muchos están esperando una ayuda del
gobierno así que esto lo analizaremos en
el transcurso de esta de esa primera
noche de una convención que como ya lo
mencionado es sui generis probert y me
quiero ir con la contraparte de esta
convención demócrata quiero saludar
nuevamente a maricruz mcgowan ella es
estratega republicana y le quiero
preguntar señora maricruz como ve a los
demócratas llegar a esta carrera por la
presidencia de eeuu que todos saber en
las urnas el próximo 3 de noviembre
buenas noches y gracias por la
invitación bueno yo creo que el partido
demócrata está llegando en este momento
de una situación muy débil y yo no
concuerdo en muchas de las aseveraciones
que sus corresponsables dijeron sobre la
situación del país la situación
económica y cómo se manejó la pandemia
es todo lo contrario este país es el
país más resiliente en términos de
respuesta a la pandemia cuando uno ve
los números por ejemplo la economía de
españa se contrajo en 22.7 por ciento la
de reunido en un 20.5 por ciento
alemania que lo hizo muy bien en 11.5
por ciento pero la economía de eeuu se
contrajo solo 10.5 por ciento de acuerdo
a los empleos en los últimos tres meses
se ha recuperado nueve millones de
empleos en los eeuu no nos olvidemos que
la recesión del 2008 se tomaron más de
cuatro años para recuperar nueve años de
empleo delante de empleos cuando ahora
se ha tomado sólo tres meses en vez de
más de cuatro años 12 cuando uno ve las
cifras se ve lo bien que esta pandemia
han sido manejada no hay ningún país que
ha hecho más tests que los eeuu
no hay ningún país que ha empezado a
producir ventiladores gracias al
presidente que sacó que uso porque ya
había eso en el acta del decreto de
defensa de producción donde muchas
compañías como los motores en donde
ctriz empezaron a producir lo que
necesita se necesitaba en ese momento
como test como ventiladores como suaves
como todo lo que necesitaban y lo han
hecho solamente por ejemplo era un motor
se les tomó 17 días para reajustar y han
fabricado 21.000 ventiladores en su
fábrica de indiana y de acuerdo y porque
se está logrando eso porque la economía
de los eeuu antes de la pandemia estaba
más fuerte que nunca estuvo en su
historia principalmente para nuestra
comunidad el pleno empleo es 4 por
ciento lo cual quiere decir que
cualquier persona que quiere trabajar
encuentra trabajo antes de la pandemia
estaba en 3.9 por ciento y de los
afroamericanos histórico tiene un
trabajo del 8.5 por ciento incluso
con el presidente obama y el presidente
clinton pero gracias al presidente camps
se bajó a 5.6 por ciento el desempleo de
los afroamericanos es la gente está
viendo y está viviendo por un lado una
prosperidad que nunca ha visto una
respuesta activa una respuesta no
hipócrita una respuesta directa que te
da soluciones y por otro lado están
viendo la violencia generada por grupos
terroristas domésticos y yo creo que la
decisión es muy fácil tienen el sueño
americano o quieren la anarquía y eso es
lo que está proponiendo o soportando
apoyando el partido demócrata no importa
cuántas conversiones virtuales tengan la
gente está viviendo día a día la cia que
era antes del presente trump y lo que
sería si el presidente de trump no es
reelegido si le interrumpo un momento
señora mayo one porque quiero ir con el
señor robert valència tocando un punto
que usted
a las protestas que se han suscitado en
eeuu a raíz de la muerte del hombre
afroamericano george flor usted dice la
señora ma cuban decía que eran grupos
terroristas domésticos qué opinión le
merece a usted señor valència sobre
estas protestas y sobre lo que estaba
diciendo la señora mcgowan
cuando indudablemente hay grupos e
incluso esto está documentado por la
policía y me remito específicamente al
ejemplo de mineápolis en donde se
mencionó que los grupos infiltrados en
estas protestas que ocasionaron desmanes
y que ocasionaron destrozos materiales
eran incluso supremacistas blancos yo
creo que hay que tener cuidado en
catalogar aún un grupo de la población
que le está está reclamando
legítimamente una reforma policial a
nivel nacional yo creo que no se puede
utilizar ese tipo de lenguaje para
seguir avivando una división racial que
existe bueno y que obviamente ha
existido antes de donald trump durante
el trump y probablemente después de
donald trump yo creo que no se puede
catalogar un grupo de personas que están
reclamando legítimamente un respeto a la
comunidad que haya inversiones en la
comunidad que haya una desfinanciación
aunque ha sido un tema bastante
álgido y que yo creo que poco entendido
porque muchos muchos hablan y cuando se
habla de una desfinanciación de la
policía se está hablando de una
abolición total de la policía y yo creo
que ese no es por lo menos el sentido de
las protestas yo creo que lo importante
aquí es señalar que indudablemente
georges floyd es un ejemplo claro como
se diría una causa célebre y en el cual
pues es el reflejo de muchas de las
atrocidades que han ocasiones se han que
han ocurrido en dentro de la comunidad
afroamericana yo realmente no sé si
seamos motivo de celebración
lo que estamos viendo con la pandemia mí
me parece que es un poco insensible
hacer ese tipo de comentarios más de 170
mil personas han fallecido más de 5
millones de infectados luego de que el
actual administración
digamos no diera direcciones concretas y
los mensajes han sido mezclados porque
recordemos que el vicepresidente mike
pence había prometido que nosotros nos
olvidaríamos
dénia de aquí a memorial day memorial
day fue el último fin de semana de mayo
y estamos en agosto y no hay digamos un
descenso en los contagios y ni hablando
del tema de los hispanos pues sí
evidentemente se ha mantenido una
economía al alza dentro digamos en estos
tres años pero desde el momento en que
la pandemia comenzó a arrasar la
economía pues los hispanos son los que
se han visto afectados no solamente por
la pérdida de vidas humanas sino también
por sus empleos 60 por ciento de los
hispanos son propensos son o han sido
propensos a perder sus empleos de hecho
una encuesta sacada el día de hoy y
revelada por la cadena en abc news el
70% de los hispanos desaprueba la
gestión de donald trump
frente al córdoba virus y no es para
menos y es la comunidad más afectada yo
que me encuentro en la ciudad de nueva
york yo que tuve la mala fortuna de
poder vivir de primera mano los efectos
del coronavirus aquí en la ciudad de
mayor la mayoría de las personas que
fueron afectadas fueron afroamericanos e
hispanos
y ahora hay también que mencionar yo
creo que ningún país tuvo la capacidad
de detener un virus de semejantes
magnitudes en su totalidad pues yo creo
que eso también sería injusto señalar al
presidente del trauma en ese aspecto sin
embargo creo que se podía haber hecho
más porque incluso un estudio de la
universidad de columbia señalaba que si
en el momento en que nosotros estábamos
en el en el punto más álgido de la del
contagio si hubiera ordenado el uso de
máscaras si hubieran prevenido más de 30
mil muertes y hoy estamos ya bordeando
las 270.000 si mal no estoy así que yo
creo que no podemos mirar las cosas
desde un digamos desde desde un lente de
color rosa y decir está
dejando bien la situación porque son son
170 y son 170 mil muertos y no solamente
es una estadística son familias enteras
que han sido devastadas por esto y
muchas de ellas son hispanas y es
precisamente como vuelvo y mencionó el
reflejo de uno de una población hispana
que no aprueban la gestión de donald
trump e incluso entrando ya hoy en la
convención demócrata los hispanos apoyan
un 60 por ciento y eso solamente me
refiero a las encuestas el 60 por ciento
incluso apoya yo bailé ahora en el
espectro de las cosas pues yo creo que
todavía la pelea está muy peleada entre
los dos hay un 4% de diferencia entre
ellos dos y ese 4% podríamos decir que
es el bar 'el en el error de margen en
entre ambos candidatos así que nada está
escrito pero yo creo que me parece que
por respeto a las víctimas hispanas y
afroamericanas no se puede uno dar auto
con bruta las congratulaciones y darse
palmadas en el hombro y decir que viene
estamos ya haciendo trabajo
y haber hecho mucho más pero yo creo que
no se puede demeritar el hecho de que
hay cientos de fallecidos muchos de
ellos hispanos y donde lo y entre los
cuales muchos se encuentran sin empleo
señora mccowan quiero volver con usted
para también hablar de lo que está
hablando el señor valència sobre la
importancia del voto hispano que también
tiende a ser un poco más a los
demócratas que a los republicanos que
cree usted que puede hacer el presidente
donald trump para robar de alguna manera
esos votos hispanos
en la bancada demócrata
ar me gustaría que me dé el mismo tiempo
que ha dado al señor robert para para
hablar por supuesto ha hablado por
teléfono cinco veces más el tiempo en el
que youtube y eso no me parece justo yo
creo que ustedes deberían balancear el
tiempo 50 50 por ciento y no darme cinco
precisión que es que tenemos dos horas
de oficiales tenemos más tiempo para
estar con usted adelante señor que
entonces empecemos que yo no estaba
celebrando la pandemia me estaba
celebrando la residencia del pueblo
americano ante la pandemia y de acuerdo
a los datos que nos presente ningún país
en el mundo
ha llevado mejor la crisis de la
pandemia que se ha recuperado y se están
recuperando tan rápido como se está
recuperando la economía de los eeuu eso
hay que aclararlo porque es sumamente
importante que bien que se manejó en los
eeuu esta pandemia obviamente nadie en
el mundo ha tenido el poder de parar la
pandemia en es mucho menos un país de
328 millones de habitantes usted no
puede comparar cuántos muertos hay en
los eeuu con españa o con brasil o con
ningún otro país porque cuando usted
suma y yo hice ese experimento compare
los eeuu la población de 328 millones de
personas con la población de los de
europa de los países que son
pertenecientes al yemen incluya para
japón y más o menos para ver la misma
cantidad de d
de muertos si eeuu tiene un porcentaje
menor de muertes que han fallecido por
el coro la mano es que todos estos
países que son igualmente avanzados
porque tampoco nos iba a comparar con
países la tierra en el campo una timba
países pobres lo compare con países del
grupo de 7 que son los países más
prósperos más ricos del mundo y nosotros
dado eso los eeuu hemos tenido la
cantidad menor de muertes uno porque se
ha manejado muy bien dos porque la
economía ya estaba en muy fuerte y hemos
tenido los recursos tres por las medidas
del presidente tram como cerrar la
frontera el 31 de enero inmediatamente
cuando en febrero
la señora pelosi demócrata quiere el
congreso estaba diciendo todo lo que
aquí no había problema y haciendo una
fiesta en el barrio chino de san
francisco entonces dejemos la hipocresía
a un lado eso no pasó
veamos la tasa de mortalidad que es lo
más importante el número de casos va a
ser más alto cuanto más test se tomen
ningún país de nuevo ha tomado más tests
percápita o sea por población que los
eeuu pero veamos la tasa de mortalidad
la tasa de mortalidad como dije es menor
que los otros países del grupo 7 es
solamente 0.33 por ciento o sea es menos
del medio por ciento de la población o
sea quiero que entiendan eso 328
millones de personas y me parece que
ahora hemos calculado 170 mil o
alrededor de esos muertos en los eeuu no
es para decir que estas muertes no
tienen ninguna importancia pero es para
ver en forma objetiva cómo se está
manejando esta crisis que es una crisis
horrible que ninguno de nosotros hubiera
querido vivirla pero la estamos viviendo
y lo que es más importante cuando una
persona tiene una crisis cuando un país
tiene una crisis es ver cómo se responde
cómo se levanta cómo se adapta y cómo
está mitigando qué es lo que está
haciendo la administración del
presidente trump hablando de los latinos
siempre hablan los demócratas los
latinos queremos esto los latinos
queremos el otro no es tan sólidos como
si los latinos vivieran en tomo en un
campo de concentración en un lugar
determinado de los eeuu no es así la
cosa
los latinos viven en todos los estados
de los eeuu si un poco menos en el norte
porque ya la mayoría de los latinos no
les gusta el clima frío básicamente eso
es y tienden a ocupar más las zonas con
un mejor clima y yo los entrevistó y
hablo con niños y la razón número uno es
ya sea que tienen familia en esos
estados o que el clima sea bueno en
latinoamérica no tenemos el clima frío
que se observa acá en el en el norte del
país y lógicamente si pueden evitar eso
lo opinan lo evitan
somos parte de la comunidad los a mí no
me gusta mucho decir hispanoamericano
prefiero decir americano de descendencia
hispana pero americano primero porque
este es nuestro país
nosotros hemos jurado lealtad cuando nos
hemos hecho ciudadanos a los eeuu
yo creo que si una persona no va a ser
leal a este país no debería hacerse
ciudadano americano nadie los está
obligando pero cuando uno hace una
promesa
hay que tener integridad y hay que ser
fiel y defender y proteger el país que
nos está dando tanto un país que no nos
dio lo que los países que vinimos
obviamente la mayoría de la gente viene
acá para mejor oportunidad y eso es lo
que tenemos acá no se puede atacar no se
puede morder la mano del que te da de
comer
la verdad no deja de asombrarse la
cortesía del partido demócrata no deja
de sonar
sí señor ama cobán gracias por su
opinión estamos viendo en pantalla un
cantante afroamericano haciéndole un
homenaje al afro americano george loud
que murió unas semanas atrás y
previamente a este homenaje que están
haciendo en este momento muchas personas
de manera virtual hicieron un minuto de
silencio por george fue escuchamos un
poco del ambiente de lo que se vive en
este momento en esta convención
demócrata
son
mi vida
aquí
[Música]
no se ha de dar
i
[Música]
cuidad
usted entonces lo estaban viendo un
homenaje a george floyd que murió a
manos de la policía
semanas atrás y ha convulsionado de
alguna manera a eeuu quiero ir a la
capital estadounidense washington dice
con nuestra corresponsal diana castañeda
diana estamos viendo en este momento una
una convención demócrata totalmente
virtual le pregunto si que si será este
modelo el que vamos a ver en las
convenciones en las convenciones futuras
porque muchos también aseguran que el
modelo anterior ya estaba obsoleto
estaba en declive
bueno definitivamente por lo menos esta
convención demócrata y la convención
republicana que se espera la próxima
semana tendrán este formato debido a la
pandemia en este caso de la convención
demócrata los demócratas se prepararon
con más de 1000 vídeos que grabaron para
la transmisión de esta de esta
convención y hemos visto cómo ha sido
liderada por la actriz eva longoria
quien es la figura más importante de la
organización latino víctor y comenzamos
viendo testimonios importantes de
ciudadanos que están mostrando la crisis
que están viviendo vimos ciudadanos por
ejemplo en el estado de pensilvania que
es un estado importante para estas
elecciones hablando de cómo se han visto
afectados sus cultivos
hemos visto agricultores también
propietarios de pequeños negocios
vimos una enfermera de texas que estaba
hablando de cómo ha tenido que responder
frente a la pandemia pero como les
preocupa también enviar de nuevo a sus
hijos a las escuelas así que digamos que
este ha sido el pan
que han dado en este digamos inicio de
la convención hablando las
preocupaciones que tienen los ciudadanos
y muchas preocupaciones hoy no sólo cómo
recuperarse cómo recuperar sus negocios
cómo pagar la renta cuando muchos no ha
podido pagar la renta y en los estados
se están tratando de establecer medidas
para que se les pueda extender este
moratorio y no sean desalojados en medio
de una pandemia de sus hogares y vimos
también a la alcaldesa de washington a
muy el dausol quien ha sido una de las
figuras más importantes del movimiento
de black life matters hablando sobre por
qué ella salía atrás en el escenario
mostrando la calle con este gran letrero
de este movimiento queda justo hacia la
casa blanca asegurando que es momento de
un cambio donde los afroamericanos que
viven injusticias raciales injusticias
sociales no vivan este panorama y
simplemente puedan salir tranquilos
hacer compras o salir a las escuelas o
montar en los autobuses sin ser
agredidos o tener miedo
con la policía habló del incidente
también que protagonizó el presidente de
un halcón cuando se realizaban protestas
por la muerte de georg floyd en frente
de la casa blanca y el presidente de
donald trump respondió a estas protestas
con gases y también caminando frente a
la casa blanca para tomarse una foto
frente a la iglesia que se encuentra en
la casa blanca después vemos a los
familiares de georg floyd este hombre
afroamericano que murió en manos de
policías blancos haciendo un homenaje a
su hermano pero también llamando a un
cambio y el tributo de un minuto de
silencio de muchos ciudadanos
afroamericanos en los eeuu veíamos las
imágenes de ellos desde sus casas dianas
gracias por ese completo resumen de lo
que ha ocurrido entonces en la
convención demócrata hasta este momento
y quiero saludar a nuestra otra invitada
ella es leonardo durán week analista
política y estratega demócrata que nos
atiende desde la ciudad de miami en
estado de florida en eeuu señor ahora
gracias por su tiempo y por estar con
nosotros
24 no sé si tuvo la oportunidad de
escuchar lo que estábamos hablando
previamente con nuestras corresponsales
y nuestros invitados en cuanto a esta
convención demócrata todos los puntos
que hemos tocado en la noche de hoy y
quiero saber su opinión qué podemos
esperar entonces de esta convención y
cómo llega a eeuu hasta hasta este
momento hasta ya las convenciones tanto
demócratas como la republicana la semana
que viene de cara estas elecciones de 3
de noviembre
hola buenas noches gracias por tenerme
acá desde miami pues yo me siento muy
bien esta noche porque finalmente
nuestro partido tiene la convención
nacional demócrata
y me ha encantado porque el futuro
presidente de los eeuu el vicepresidente
joe biden en este momento pues tuvo la
iniciativa de hacer una convención
virtual desde la casa por la cantidad de
casos que hay de kobin haití en este
país
la señora estuvo diciendo maricruz
estuvo diciendo que eeuu tiene una de
las menores tasas mundiales no es cierto
cuánta es la población de eeuu cuál es
la por cuál es el número de muertos que
hay en eeuu
mira hay 5.4 millones de personas
contagiadas y nosotros tenemos 170 mil
muertos
entonces si tú te vas a cualquier país
europeo o te vas a cualquier país
oriental como la china y relación con
todos esos países nosotros
sido los peores la crisis del cobi 19
eeuu ha dado muestras de la ineptitud
con la que el presidente trump la ha
manejado
gracias por su opinión entonces señora
leonardo durán no sé si tenemos un poco
de ambiente de lo que está ocurriendo en
esta convención demócrata escuchemos
algo de lo que dice el candidato
joe byd en ese momento o mejor a una
entrevista que está en este momento
haciendo uso de su palabra escuchamos un
poco lo que ocurre
cuando se trata de la brutalidad
policial porque ese ha sido un problema
de mucho tiempo bueno creo que la gente
está lista creo que la gente está lista
simplemente tenemos que seguir empujando
no podemos dejar que esto continúe
muchas gracias gracias por reunirse a mí
en esta conversación
el racismo es esto finalmente es ruido y
sistemáticamente es real no importa cómo
te veas y nunca deberías tener miedo por
el color de tu piel lo que yo quiero ver
en el próximo presidente de eeuu es
alguien que sea justo
y que ponga a la justicia vidas de
manera equitativa para todos y que
lidere esta revolución que estamos
experimentando joe biden y sensus
sanador y es un unificador que va a
luchar por el movimiento black lexmark
él va a acabar con lo que queda del
sistema de justicia sistemático con las
cosas que en las cuales nuestro país no
le ha puesto atención tenemos que
defender esta plataforma e introducir
una legislación que haga que estos sean
los valores que llevamos en el corazón
y quiero que este mundo
pero que sea mejor para él
[Música]
we the people a ello tenían nosotros el
pueblo también es el eje principal de
esta convención demócrata que recordemos
va hasta el próximo jueves 20 de agosto
quiero entonces retomar un poco lo que
la discusión que estábamos teniendo por
en otro punto de vista hablemos ahora de
el candidato demócrata joe biden quién
es joe biden y cómo llega hasta este
punto y quiero retomar entonces la
comunicación con la señora leonarda
durantes de la ciudad de miami y señora
durante luces de palabra
hola sí de nuevo aquí contigo pues el
senado el él empezó como el de abajo yo
bailé y es es la realización del sueño
americano en un servidor público siempre
ha sido un servidor público ha llegado
al lugar donde está hoy por su trabajo
porque siempre ha defendido los derechos
del pueblo
americano y de todas las personas que
tenemos yo vaivén ha tenido muchas
desgracias en su vida y él las ha
superado y eso nos muestra la cantidad
de valor que hay en ese hombre nos
muestra como ese hombre pudo enfrentar
esas crisis personales y convertirlas en
hoy crisis sino en herramientas para
seguir trabajando por este país
señor valencia es la ciudad de nueva
york quiero volver nuevamente con usted
y entonces preguntarle lo que le
preguntaba básicamente a la señora
durante cómo llega yo vaivén hasta esta
candidatura demócrata para luchar contra
el presidente de donald trump que busca
su reelección el 3 de noviembre
bueno obviamente yo bailé en es una
persona que ya tiene un bagaje histórico
desde el punto de vista político
bueno vicepresidente de la campaña bueno
también de la administración de barack
obama y precisamente a esa ex por esa
exposición por el hecho de haber formado
parte de los dos años de administración
de barack obama le dio la visibilización
y de aquila y en la cual muchos de los
demócratas ya han amparado en que yo
bailén sea el ganador de las elecciones
ahora cuando cuando nos estamos
acercando
al mes de noviembre ahora hay hay una
hay una cosa que hay que mencionar que
me parece muy importante yo no sé qué
tanto que tanta emoción despierte yo
vaivén realmente yo creo que muchos
esperaban una digamos una llave
demócrata un poco más radical si se
quiere decir porque obviamente puede ser
prensa anders y contando con el apoyo de
alexandría o acaso corte
muchos creerían que el partido demócrata
sería el partido del que anti
establecimiento casi que de la misma
forma que fue la plataforma de donde
donald trump hace unos cuatro unas 124
años con lo cual yo creo que yo es la de
la manera en la que el partido
demócratas confío a joe biden y acá
demandan xerez es precisamente por eso
asegurarle a la mayoría por lo menos de
los estadounidenses o por lo menos del
establecimiento de que eso de que ellos
dos son precisamente eso son figuras del
establecimiento no una figura radical yo
diría que si yo bailé no hubiese
escogido a elizabeth warren pues se wall
street' estaría muy preocupado pero
escogió a canadá here is que incluso
según reportes que han salido
recientemente pues hueso y ahora respira
más tranquilo porque es kamala harris
pues no es tan recalcitrante con el tema
de wall street como lo fuese por ejemplo
elisabeth word así que yo bailé
básicamente es la llave segura para
calmar los ánimos dentro de distintos
sectores
de estados unidos tanto en silicon
valley california como en wall street
ahora joe biden llega a con una ventaja
relativamente amplia con respecto al
presidente de donald trump que busca su
reelección como le decíamos este 3 de
noviembre logrará mantener ese ímpetu el
candidato by the end cuando estamos a
menos de 3 meses de estas elecciones
presidenciales
pregunta va dirigida a mi verdad si
robert si bueno indudablemente las las
encuestas fluctúan de acuerdo a las
circunstancias vimos por ejemplo hace un
par de semanas donde había una gran
diferencia incluso de doble dígito entre
joe biden y donald trump ahora algunas
encuestas señalan que esa ventaja se ha
disminuido un poco es decir ya no es 12%
de ventajas sino que ahora estamos
hablando de un 45 por ciento así que
obviamente vamos a ver el desempeño de
estas kahn de estas candidaturas a lo
largo de estos ya prácticamente 79 días
que es lo que resta de aquí en noviembre
pero indudablemente creo que hay un
punto muy importante al mencionar yo
creo que aunque joe biden pueda tener
una ligera ventaja sobre donald trump
todavía le resta por lo menos conquistar
el voto es para lo que aunque tiene un
60% todavía necesita conquistar el voto
de los indecisos el voto de los
independientes las personas que viven en
la florida que viven en ohio que viven
en
en carolina del norte que son estados
que se consideran pendular es todavía no
se sabe hacia esa cierta ciencia cierta
hacia qué inc
hacia qué inclinación tienen ellos se
dice mira por ambos lados así que yo
creo que joe biden puede incluso mostrar
de equipo de robert aragon y astro si lo
interrumpo en este momento para escuchar
las declaraciones del gobernador del
estado nueva york andrew cuomo y luego
vuelvo con usted
vamos a escuchar al gobernador de nueva
york andrew co
agradecer a los 30.000
y estadounidenses que vinieron aquí para
ayudarnos en nuestro momento de
necesidad es su amor nos dio la
posibilidad de continuar pasamos por el
infierno pero hemos aprendido mucho
sabemos que nuestros problemas van más
allá del virus del virus
este es el síntoma no la enfermedad es
nuestra nación está en crisis y en
muchas maneras el quid es solamente una
metáfora un virus que ataca cuando el
cuerpo está débil cuando no puede
defenderse
en estos últimos años las políticas y
eeuu han sido débiles ha habido un
sentimiento t latino anti inmigrante ha
habido racismo en charlottesville con el
eco kux klan ni siquiera quiso
esconderse y en minnesota donde se acabó
la vida del señor flores solamente un
cuerpo fuerte puede luchar contra un
virus y las divisiones de eeuu nos
debilitó donald trump no creo
esta división inicial la división creo a
trump en solamente la empeoró nuestra
fortaleza se ejerce a través del
gobierno es nuestro sistema inmune y en
este momento nuestro gobierno es
incompetente no podía luchar contra el
virus de hecho ni siquiera lo vio venir
el virus europeo llegó al noreste
mientras la casa blanca a un estado
hablando de china el virus había estado
atacando nos durante meses antes de que
siquiera se dieran cuenta que estaba
aquí vimos el fracaso de un gobierno que
trató de negar este virus que trato
ignorarlo y después trató de politizarlo
el gobierno fallido que vio como esta
como nueva york fue víctima de esta
negligencia y nosotros aprendimos así
que hoy seis meses después de haber
comenzado la nación aún no está
preparada y ahora nos enfrentamos a una
segunda amenaza pero esta vez no de otra
naturaleza esta es una amenaza hecha por
el hombre hecha por nuestra propia
negligencia ahora vemos al virus
expandiéndose por el país de un estado
al otro
estamos por detrás del mundo en la lucha
contra el cometemos más de 5 millones de
casos y hemos aprendido una lección
crítica que tan vulnerables somos cuando
estamos divididos en cuántas vidas
pueden perderse cuando nuestro gobierno
es incompetente pero hemos aprendido
otras cosas vimos lo negativo pero
también lo positivo nosotros probamos
que nuestra manera funcionó y tuvo éxito
que podemos levantarnos entre la
educación que podemos poner de lado las
diferencias y encontrar un terreno común
el gobierno puede decir la verdad y
construir confianza podemos juzgar por
el contento por el contenido del
carácter y no el color de la piel que
podemos trabajar juntos y forjar
comunidades y un gobierno competente que
por supuesto vamos a aportar más caras
porque somos inteligentes y porque me
importas y porque yo te importa por
supuesto que vamos a distanciarnos
socialmente porque quedarnos lejos
muestra que tan cerca nos estamos
realmente si vamos a establecer
y rastrear y el rastreo porque somos
estadounidenses ganamos guerras y somos
el mejor país del mundo y a pesar del
dolor en las lágrimas nuestra manera
funcionó y fue hermoso mostramos que
estos ángeles son fuertes que
respondimos al llamado vimos que incluso
al final del día incluso si fue un día
largo el amor gana al final los ojos de
eeuu se han abierto y hemos visto aquí
la verdad de que el gobierno importa y
el liderazgo importa y determina si
triunfamos o si morimos o vivimos
necesitamos un líder que sea tan bueno
como nuestra gente un líder que haga un
llamado a lo mejor dentro de nosotros no
lo peor un líder que pueda unirnos no
dividirnos un líder que pueda
levantarnos yo conozco a esa persona he
trabajado con ese hombre he visto su
talento he visto su fortaleza he visto
su dolor he visto su corazón
ese hombre es joe by the flow vaivén es
lo que yo llamo un grupo estadounidense
rudo la mejor manera
un rudo inteligente una persona que une
que es disciplinada y que es amorosa el
poder restaurar el alma de eeuu y eso es
exactamente lo que nuestro país necesita
ahora gracias
lo tenían era el gobernador del estado
de nueva york el demócrata andrew cuomo
y quiero volver con la señora en la
capital de eeuu washington dc maricruz
mcgowan y opinión
y qué opinión le merece entonces no
vamos a escuchar un poco entonces de lo
que está ocurriendo en esta convención
demócrata y después vuelvo con la señora
mcgowan que está bajo control y que iba
a desaparecer que se podían acabar con
las reglas de distanciamiento que no
tenía
en arizona mi padre fue a un bar de
karaoke con sus amigos y unas semanas
después estaba con un ventilador y
después de cinco días a conscientes
murió solo en una uci con una enfermera
teniendo de la mano él era un hombre
saludable de 65 años su única condición
preexistente fue confiar en donald trump
y por eso pagó con su vida no estamos
más sola cuando le cuento mi historia
muchas personas vinieron hacia mí para
compartir la suya me preguntaron que les
ayudará y vieron que le ayudara para
mantener la comunidad
sobre todo las de color de manera segura
que han sido afectadas de manera
desproporcionada me pidieron a mí a una
persona normal que ayudar porque donald
trump no lo haría el coronavirus ha
dejado claro que hay dos países en eeuu
en donde vive o nacho y la otra donde
murió mi padre ya es suficiente todo eso
que tal vez no haya causado el
coronavirus pero su falta de honestidad
y sus acciones irresponsables hicieron
que fuera mucho peor necesitamos un
líder que tenga un plan coordinado
basado en los datos a nivel nacional
para detener esta pandemia y evitar que
maten más personas para poder reabrir de
manera segura el país necesitamos un
líder que llegue a él desde el primer
día y haga su trabajo que le importamos
nosotros una de las últimas cosas que me
dijo mi padre fue que el cen se sentía
traicionado por donación entonces cuando
ponga mi voto por joe biden lo haré por
mi padre
y ustedes entonces tenían en pantalla el
testimonio de una persona una mujer que
perdió a su padre por la enfermedad de
kobe 19 y es que anteriormente a eso
veíamos las declaraciones y también el
discurso del gobernador del estado de
nueva york el demócrata el demócrata
andrew cuomo el haber él habló de que
eeuu era una nación que actualmente
estaba en crisis dijo que la nación
estaba a manos de políticos débiles
también habló del racismo que se ha
aumentado en eeuu según lo dijo el el
gobernador del estado nueva york andrew
cuomo por supuesto también habló de las
divisiones dijo que el presidente un
antro nació de estas divisiones y
empeoró la división social y racial en
el país también apeló a la bondad de los
estadounidenses ya la unidad del pueblo
estadounidense y dijo que juntos
pudieran poner de lado está
diferencias también por supuesto hablo
de la pandemia de kobe 19 que golpeó
fuertemente al estado de nueva york uno
de los más golpeados por esta pandemia
en ese país dijo que iban a seguir
haciendo uso de las mascarillas y
también dijo que iban a seguir teniendo
entonces el distanciamiento social y
obviamente apoyo a el candidato
demócrata joe biden dijo que con joe
biden el país se podía unirse de nuevo y
podía tener un mejor liderazgo antes de
esta declaración de como yo quería
conversar con la señora mccowan ella es
estratega republicana y se encuentra en
la capital de eeuu en washington dice yo
le quiero preguntar a usted señora
mccowan si cree que entonces en las
palabras del gobernador de nueva york
andrew como galán en una sociedad en
eeuu le quiero preguntar sobre el
racismo y las divisiones y qué le
pareció el discurso del señor
respecto a la alcoba 19 el testimonio de
la hija del señor que murió por esta
enfermedad
bueno sí por lo menos la mitad de las
aceleraciones que hacen nuestros
considerados demócratas fueran la verdad
sería más fácil para mí opinar pero
primero que todo quisiera decir que
siento mucho que el padre de esta
muchacha haya muerto así como también
todas las personas que han fallecido por
cahuín lighting y por otras causas por
no tener atención porque por dedicarnos
al cob en haití también hubo muchas
muertes que no se expresaron la atención
que no se cuidan donde se murieron pero
hay que ver en toda la declaración de la
muchacha primero porque fue más fácil y
luego voy a hablar de las declaraciones
del gobernador y la misma dice que su
padre fue a una fiesta de karaoke cuando
todos sabíamos que había que mantener la
distancia social todos los días hacia el
presidente trump una presentación desde
la casa blanca donde se decía una y otra
vez y otra vez que había que seguir
lavarse las manos de lanzamiento social
etcétera yo creo que una persona tiene
que tomar responsabilidad por sus
acciones en ningún momento la muchacha
dijo que el presidente extra ordenó o
instigó a que las personas vayan y se
reúnan fue totalmente lo contrario una
actitud muy responsable ir a un cambio
que lo siento mucho no también es muy
responsable todas las manifestaciones
violentas que estamos viendo por todo el
país por parte de los demócratas muchos
de ellos ni siquiera tienen mascarilla y
salen vuelven a sus casas contagian
entre ellos hay muchas minorías
desgraciadamente y claro igualmente
vuelven y contagian a sus familias sobre
lo que dijo
el gobernador como él se fue uno de los
primeros que agradeció al presidente
camps por la ayuda que la administración
de trump le dio nueva york cuando él
pidió ventiladores inmediatamente se
mandaron ventiladores a nueva york y
solamente para ver que nunca
había un montón de ventiladores en nueva
york que no estaban usando es más les
mandaron un barco flotante un hospital
flotante mi padre tres ex de navalcán
porter nuestra muy segura de eso que
estuvo ahí afuera esperándola el exceso
de pacientes que decía el gobernador
como que había que no había y al lugar
en los hospitales y estuvo ahí bastante
tiempo estacionado ahí sin ningún
paciente y se tuvo que ir porque nadie
lo usó lugar quiere decir que no había
falta al daño que él ya decía tan
necesidad si había la necesidad pero si
había también como cómo responder no ha
habido ni un paciente en todos los
estados unidos nueva york o no que haya
necesitado un ventilador y no lo haya
tenido lo tienen nosotros incluso
estamos ayudando a otros países porque
hemos producido gracias al la ley de
defensa de producción del presidente
prop entonces lo que sí
al gobernador como que dijo que este es
un país extraordinario eso se le
agradece porque es así que deben hablar
los americanos en cambio hay muchos
otros demócratas en el congreso que
incluso están muy satisfechos con la
falta de respeto a la bandera con quemar
a la bandera con no no dar un honor a la
bandera cuando está tocando el himno
nacional eso es realmente muy deprimente
tuviera que ser americanos y luego que
ser republicanos o demócratas o
independientes al salto del
vicepresidente biden que va a ser esto
esto y el otro y que ha empezado de
abajo no ha empezado de abajo y en los
eeuu y en cualquier país principalmente
a los estados unidos cuando uno empieza
de diputado de miembro del congreso no
es empezar de abajo es empezar de muy
arriba
él ha estado en el congreso primero en
la cámara baja luego en la cámara alta
como senador más de 45 años y los
últimos ocho años como vicepresidente o
sea de esos 45 y tantos les cuenten los
8 años que lo que ese presidente
cuántos logros ha tenido ninguno y ahora
me viene a decir que ahora sí va a ser
todo lo que no hizo en más de 45 años
porque tenemos que creer eso quiero ir
ahora con nuestra corresponsal en nueva
york' mamen salas era mcgowan gracias
por su opinión en este momento mamen
hablemos un poco de lo que fue el
discurso del gobernador de nueva york
andrew cuomo y la actualidad de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 en el estado de
nueva york
si puesto ha sido un discurso muy
interesante un poquito la línea de esos
discursos que hemos visto en durante
esta pandemia esas conexiones que ha
ofrecido diariamente informando de cuál
era la situación es interesante también
tener en cuenta que ha participado el
gobernador andrew como que no se
postulaba como candidato para el puesto
demócrata para pelear las elecciones
mientras que el alcalde de la ciudad de
nueva york bill de blasio que sí que lo
que lo hizo no participará en esta
convención creo que nos da una idea del
grado de importancia que ha tomado a
andrew como en esta gestión y aunque sí
que es verdad que nueva york fue una de
las primeras de los primeros estados y
de los más castigados en un principio yo
creo que lo importante y lo que andrew
como aboga es que nos tenemos que quedar
con que ha conseguido salir a flote de
ese problema ha sido interesante también
escucharle en un discurso en la
convención demócrata que ya escuchamos
también hace 36 años a su padre además
durante esta pandemia hemos escuchado
por parte de muchos estadounidenses que
se preguntaban por qué andrew como no se
presentaba
como candidato demócrata en estas
elecciones el día dijo que de momento no
quería que estaba muy tranquilo muchos
dicen que no se descarta para otra
legislatura veremos a ver qué ocurre
pero yo creo que andrew como lo que ha
hecho ha sido poner un poco en contexto
la realidad que estamos viviendo y
mostrar a los estadounidenses lo
importante que es el tener un capitán
que dirija a este barco de manera
conjunta en la misma dirección que es un
poquito lo que lo que precisamente
muchos se han quejado durante esta
pandemia y que no hubiese una dirección
clara o una orden a nivel nacional
dentro de todo el país sin ir más lejos
por ejemplo ahora mismo no hay una
restricción o una norma clara acerca del
uso o no de mascarillas en la vía
pública o en los centros cada estado
continúa autogestionándose igual ha
faltado un poquito de unidad en ese
sentido y precisamente por eso es lo que
está apostando el candidato demócrata
joe by dan
así es mamen quiero ir entonces ahora
con robert valencia que se encuentra en
la misma ciudad donde se encuentra usted
en la ciudad de nueva york para hablar
un poco más de esta pandemia de koi 19
que sin duda es el punto principal y de
lo que habló el gobernador del estado de
nueva york andrew cuomo el presidente
donald trump asegura y ha asegurado
varias veces que el virus irá pronto y
promete además una pronta recuperación
económica en el país qué tan realista
son estos comentarios del presidente y
qué tan rápida puede ser esta
recuperación económica en eeuu
me parece que hay que hacer un par de
apreciaciones con la intervención que
hizo la señora de washington y lo voy a
hacer no sólo como un analista más sino
como un ciudadano de nueva york que ha
vivido palmo a palmo lo que pasó aquí en
los momentos más álgidos y más difíciles
de la pandemia me parece que me parece
curioso que se juzgue al gobernador
cuomo y yo sin ser de parte de la nómina
de leandro como para dejarlo en claro
pero si el solicitar el buque comfort y
abrir tiendas de campaña en el parque
central con cámaras que no fueron
utilizadas pues que mejor noticia que
eso que no se usaron esas cámaras porque
la verdad y esto fue precisamente el
discurso que impulsó a angie como a la
palestra nacional fue cuando encaró al
presidente de donald trump y le dijo
señor presidente yo estoy utilizando sus
números de la cdc que es el centro
se me escapa el nombre de español pero
es el centro para enfermedades que se
encuentran en la ciudad de atlanta
el cdc en inglés si no las proyecciones
pena interrumpirte nuevamente pero
apenas termine la gobernadora música en
su intervención vuelva inmediatamente
contigo escuchemos en la administración
de walmart by the box heredó la peor
crisis económica desde la gran depresión
la de la industria automotriz que estaba
a punto de colapsar un millón de
empleados estaban en juego pero el
presidente obama y el vicepresidente
biden no perdieron el tiempo culpando a
la gente o evitando su responsabilidad
se pusieron a trabajar se unieron a los
sindicatos ya las empresas y salvaron es
esa industria automotriz
quién lo diría hace unos cuantos meses a
medida que comenzamos a cómo luchar con
tercovi los trabajadores de esta
industria se pusieron en acción y
comenzaron a hacer equipo de protección
para los médicos y para las enfermeras
vengan permítanme explicar al presidente
obama y el vicepresidente biden salvaron
las formas de vida de estas personas y
ellos después hicieron su parte para
salvar vidas estadounidenses esa es la
historia de esta gran nación
la acción lleva a más acción el progreso
lleva a más progreso y cuando trabajamos
juntos podemos cumplir cualquier cosa
después de todo la democracia es un
deporte de equipos especialmente ahora
es crucial que nos unamos para luchar
contra este virus y reconstruir mejor
nuestra economía
nosotros tomamos esta pandemia desde el
principio muy en serio en michigan
escuchamos a los expertos
planeamos y con el trabajo de los
trabajadores de la industria automotriz
y con poco trabajo la casa blanca
ejecutamos un plan salvando miles de
vidas
solamente imaginen si hubiésemos tenido
una estrategia nacional para que
cualquier persona que necesita una
prueba puede obtener la gratis para que
la gente pueda acceder a una vacuna para
que los reeducadores puedan volver a las
escuelas con hayden y harris en la casa
blanca lo tendremos bay de níjar les van
a liderar con el ejemplo visa será la
ciencia no la política o el ego la que
va a liderar a guiar sus decisiones
ellos saben que la salud de la gente va
de la mano con una economía fuerte y
saben que la acción lleva a más acción
en los últimos meses hemos aprendido que
es lo esencial levantarse entre los
retos no negar los hemos aprendido quién
es esencial también no solamente los
ricos no solamente un presidente
que prefiere luchar contra los
estadounidenses que contra el virus es
la gente que pone su propia salud en
riesgo para cuidar al resto de nosotros
ellos son los importantes los médicos
los los camioneros los profesores las
enfermeras los que llevan al correo y
los trabajadores de la industria
automotriz así que estas personas muchas
personas han perdido su vida por el
cobre
más de 170 mil personas en el país han
muerto en el país incluyendo una niña de
5 años de visión llamada skyles cuya
madre es una oficial de policía y su
padre es un bombero que nosotros
generación nos hemos definido por lo que
hacemos o lo que hemos fallado en hacer
entonces por skyler por sus padres y en
la memoria de todos aquellos que hemos
perdidos actuemos tenemos como una sola
nación
encontremos la fortaleza para hacer el
trabajo necesario
y ustedes la veían en pantalla era la
gobernadora del estado de michigan en
estados unidos- gretchen witmer y ahora
si vuelvo nuevamente con robert valencia
de la ciudad de nueva york analista
político internacional robert que pena a
nuevamente me disculpo con ustedes pero
tiene que entender que también tenemos
que interrumpir en este momento para
escuchar un poco de lo que ocurre en la
convención demócrata en ese momento
adelante
si no no ni más faltaba de eso se trata
estamos aquí para eso bueno volviendo no
me quiero extender mucho con lo de juego
porque me parece que lo de como ya pasó
pero si quería hacer esa precisión de
que al principio si fue muy difícil para
algo como solicitar los ventiladores y
solicitar el buque que las habitadas
mencionando precisamente porque se había
politizado el tema del coronavirus y el
presidente de trump en aquel entonces
que insistía en que nueva york y otros
estados no requerían de los ventiladores
e incluso puso a competir a distintos
estados para ver quién compraba más
mascarillas y otros accesorios así que
yo creo que el uso del el desuso si
quiere llamar así del buque y de los de
las candelas y tiendas de campaña pues
me parece que ese es momento de
celebración porque para que queremos ver
algo arriba abarrotado de pacientes pues
simplemente se devolvió al buque y se
cerraron las las tiendas de campaña y
eso y esa confrontación que tuvo como
lo llevo a la palestra nacional y
precisamente lo tenemos como la figura
principal ahora con el tema de la
gobernadora de michigan me parece que es
un punto importante rescatarlo porque si
hay alguna crítica que le pueden hacer
los republicanos a los demócratas es que
ahora el partido demócrata se divide en
facciones progresistas costeros por qué
porque kamala harris es de california y
joe biden es de delaware y los que están
en el medio pues básicamente no quedan
representados en la llave hacia la
candidatura de los eeuu es decir estados
clave como me siguen como a yo como
wisconsin pues dentro del ticket
presidencial de donde demócrata perdón
pues no figura no figura por ejemplo el
cross john whitmer que fue también otra
de las figuras sobresalientes entre ese
rifirrafe entre el gobierno federal y
los gobiernos estatales así que yo creo
que ahí es donde los demócratas van a
tener que hacer uno
mayor esfuerzo para conquistar ese voto
de lo que conocemos como el medio oeste
estadounidense es aparte de que también
determina quién va a ser el próximo
creciente y me refiero precisamente a
ese a esa franja del país que comprende
los estados que acabo de mencionar me
siguen
ohio y wisconsin y pensilvania también
que son los considerados los estados del
cinturón del óxido como se conoce aquí
en eeuu pero quería hacer esa
apreciación sobre sobre andy como que se
le puede criticar cualquier cosa pero
indudablemente ha hecho una gestión
sobresaliente al grado de que pasamos de
ser un a un estado con una epidemia a
hacer unos estados con menores índices
de contagio vamos de inmediato con john
cage y que escuchemos
lo que está en juego es muy grande más
grande que en cualquier momento de la
historia moderna muchos hemos estado
preocupados por el camino que hemos
estado siguiendo en los últimos cuatro
años es un camino que nos ha llevado a
la división a la disfunción a la
irresponsabilidad y a generar conflictos
entre nuestros ciudadanos con seguir por
ese camino va a tener consecuencias
terribles para el alma estadounidense
porque nos están llevando por la ruta
equivocada por un presidente que nos ha
puesto unos contra otros es el va en
contra de los otros líderes que hemos
tenido que han tratado de acabar con
nuestras diferencias en llevarnos hacia
un estados unidos unidos yo soy un
republicano de larga data pero eso queda
en segundo lugar con respecto a mi
responsabilidad con este país es por eso
que he decidido aparecer en esta
convención en tiempos normales esto
probablemente nunca ocurriría pero estos
no son tiempos normales me siento
orgulloso de la herencia republicana es
el partido de lincoln que él fundó
sobre un gran propósito pero lo que he
sido testigo en los últimos años va en
contra de sus principios muchos de
nosotros no podemos imaginar otros
cuatro años por este mismo camino y es
por eso que les estoy pidiendo que se
unan a mí en elegir una mejor manera una
mejor vida creo que lo mejor de eeuu
está por venir pero solo cuando volvamos
a descubrir nuestra creencia en un
estados unidos de américa por el futuro
de nuestros hijos que puede ser
brillante el lleno de esperanza
inspirado
si elegimos que sea de esa manera he
conocido a joe biden por 30 años conozco
su historia de dolor que ha afectado su
carácter de manera profunda sé que él es
un buen hombre un hombre de fe un
unificador una persona que comprende las
esperanzas los sueños del hombre común y
de la mujer común es un hombre que puede
ayudarnos a ver la humanidad en cada uno
de nosotros él sabe que el pasado el
para el camino para restaurar esto viene
de la unidad y del propósito común para
todos
si de áreas donde él y yo estamos
absolutamente en desacuerdo pero eso
está bien porque de eso se trata este
país porque a pesar de las diferencias
nos respetamos como seres humanos cada
uno de nosotros buscando justicia y
buscando propósito todos podemos ver lo
que está ocurriendo en nuestro país el
día de hoy y todas las preguntas que
enfrentamos en ninguna persona o partido
tiene las respuestas pero lo que sí
sabemos es que podemos hacer algo mejor
de lo que hemos estado viendo hoy y sé
que yo vaivén con su experiencia y su
sabiduría y su decencia pueden unirnos
para ayudarnos a encontrar esa mejor
manera estoy seguro de que hay
republicanos e independientes que no
podían imaginar
apoyaron demócratas creen que
job aiden se vaya demasiado la izquierda
pero yo no creo que sea así porque
conozco la mesura de este hombre sé que
es razonable respetuoso lleno de fe y
nadie se mete con intel eres una persona
para nuestros tiempos tiempos que hacen
un llamado para que todos nosotros nos
quitemos el gorro partidistas y pensemos
en nosotros y por supuesto pensemos en
nuestros hijos
cuando eeuu escoge el camino correcto si
se une como lo hemos hecho tantas veces
en el pasado podemos soñar en grande y
podemos ver el final de la montaña como
un eeuu unidos con una alma que sea
la esperanza del mundo ahí entonces
ustedes lo tenían en pantalla era john
cage y un representante emblemático
republicano del movimiento anti donald
trump anti el presidente y presidente
donald trump también fue ex gobernador
del estado de ohio y por supuesto quiero
irme a la capital de eeuu washington dc
y quiero volver con la estratega
republicana economista y vocera de
comité nacional republicano
maricruz mcgowan qué opinión le merece
de estas estas personas importantes del
partido republicano que ahora están en
contra de la reelección del presidente
de eeuu donald trump que está pasando a
lo mejor dentro del partido republicano
bueno el presidente no era el típico
republicano cuando entró en esta campaña
él sí ha corrido por el pacto
republicano porque lógicamente en la
política de los eeuu para ganar no tiene
que correr representando el partido
demócrata o el partido republicano
corren por otros partidos pero ya
sabemos que la probabilidad de ganar es
muy baja muy cerca pero él ha tenido su
propio movimiento un movimiento que se
ha ido en contra de un establecimiento
donde en algún momento él también
pertenecía una élite que estaba a cargo
de la economía del país de la política
del país pero que no se estaba llevando
por decadencia por lo menos por unos 24
años por el camino equivocado
era uno de esos billonarios yo lo
llamaría casi un millonario desertor no
que puso primero su país y que luego
lógicamente todas esas personas no lo
odiaban y los odian no porque no está
haciendo un buen trabajo sino porque no
lo pueden controlar este es un hombre
que representa a lo que dice la
constitución with the people nosotros
los ciudadanos representa gente
americana un hombre que ha llevado la
economía del país principalmente para
los pobres no para los ricos para los
que aquí llamamos blue colash workers o
sea los trabajadores de cuello azul los
que no están de traje y corbata tiene un
can estado también después de que donald
trump ha llegado a presidente la
cantidad de logros que hay él ha tomado
en tres años estoy hablando de antes de
la pandemia es extraordinaria los
afroamericanos nunca han estado también
yo no sé por qué los demócratas
en que no es racista que no está tomando
en cuanto a los afroamericanos que ahora
debería solucionarse el problema de la
raza no hubiera sido más adecuado más
efectivo más sincero esperar eso cuando
tenían un presidente afroamericano
durante la presidencia del presidente
obama ni siquiera el desempleo de los
afroamericanos sufrió ni por medio por
ciento ha bajado de iraní por medio por
ciento se quedó en 8.5 y fluctuando
incluso por encima de eso incluso por en
dobles dígitos por primera vez en la
historia se bajó el desempleo de los
afroamericanos gracias presidente trump
a 5.6 por ciento si es por eso que
cuando el candidato dijo voten por mí
porque ustedes no tienen nada que perder
nadie los ayudará hasta este momento lo
mismo con los hispanos nunca
los hispanos han estado también como han
estado desde que entró presidente
presidente trump porque porque él
representa a la gente al pueblo a los
olvidados no es ni tanto al partido
republicano oficialmente es el partido
republicano pero yo diría que su
movimiento el que le llamen llamaríamos
el tram sismo como ustedes quieran
llamarlo pero no es el partido
republicano que conocíamos y de igual
manera el partido demócrata tampoco es
el partido demócrata de jhon kennedy que
incluso en ese entonces pensaban más
cerca de lo que piensa donas rompe en el
momento se ha vuelto más a la extrema
izquierda radical y eso es muy
preocupante señora mcgowan
gracias por su opinión y ahora quiero
volver un poco con el ambiente que
ocurre en esta convención demócrata de
este año que recordemos está haciendo de
manera virtual por todo aquello de la
pandemia de coronavirus o íbamos con la
senadora por el estado de nevada
catering cortes
y que nunca antes van a votar desde
lugares como este desde la sala de su
cocina ejerciendo su derecho fundamental
desde casa pero a pesar de lo que he
dicho el presidente votar por mí por
correo ha sido algo seguro durante
décadas en 2016 33 millones de
estadounidenses votaron por correo
incluso donald trump pidió un voto en
ausencia dos veces este año así que esta
vez muchos van a decidir votar de manera
presencial con una mascarilla mientras
que muchos otros votaremos por correo
aquí en nevada
seguimos los consejos de los expertos y
escuchamos a las personas de nevada para
establecer un sistema de voto por email
por correo para que la gente tenga
opciones pero todo lo que está tratando
de dividirnos dañando ese derecho
está amenazando con retirar fondos a
nevada y eso está financiando nuestras
escuelas y nuestras personas de la
tercera edad pero nosotros
hemos pedido a los jueces que no
escuchen esta petición y está poniendo
la vida de personas en riesgo al atacar
al sistema postal lo que significa que
muchos personas de sara no pueden
recibir sus medicinas porque él quiere
ganar una elección bueno señor
presidente no estamos intimidados por
usted estados unidos no está intimidada
por usted estamos unidos por valores
compartidos por una historia compartida
y por los derechos compartidos
incluyendo nuestro derecho fundamental
al voto y vamos a enviar al joe biden a
la casa blanca y vamos a voltear el
senador sacando a mis manos del poder y
con una mayoría demócrata en el senado
vamos a expandir estos derechos al voto
y a protegerlos y para hacerlo
necesitamos que están de nuestro lado
así que vayan el show baidu.com en este
momento para aportar y ayúdenos a
cambiar el senado
para recuperar la cámara alta mitch
mcconnell saben cómo dividirnos pero
nosotros sabemos cómo mantenernos unidos
y cambiar la situación
la senadora por el estado de nevada
catering cortes más toquen estaba
tocando un punto muy importante que está
en la palestra pública en este momento
en eeuu y es por supuesto el voto por
correo porque estas elecciones se dan en
una crisis sanitaria la peor en un siglo
en eeuu él le preguntó entonces a robert
valencia en la ciudad de nueva york
porque el presidente donald trump
asegura que habrá fraude en esta en
estos votos que llegarán por correo
donde se espera que más de la mitad de
los ciudadanos opten por esta medida por
el miedo al contagio por ccoo y 19no
centros de votación bueno yo creo que el
presidente de donald trump
creo que tiene una siempre lo ha
demostrado en estos tres años y medio de
que no tiene una definición o una
interpretación clara de la ley inclusive
se anunció esta semana que tanto melania
nelson como él mismo había solicitado
el voto por correo porque es claro y
evidente que eso no es ningún tipo de
fraude es decir esto ya no lo digo yo lo
han documentado personas que son
expertas y hay estudios que nos señalan
de que un fraude por correo es
prácticamente nulo puede que haya algún
tipo de problema pero en el en el grueso
en el grande contexto de las cosas pues
yo creo que eso no es así no es cierto
no hay digamos fraude por y por correo
porque incluso también el que lien
conway que es una de sus consejeras y
que él imagen y que es la secretaria de
prensa también votaron por correo es
decir yo creo que si el presidente y las
personas que lo rodean pueden votar por
correo porque no lo puede hacer la
población yo creo que aquí el problema
también que sé que es evidente es la
opresión del votante
me llama la atención cuando se dice que
el presidente está a favor del pueblo
pero recordemos lo que pasó en georgia
el hecho de que las personas de color
tuvieran tuvieron que haber hecho fila
por horas y horas para poder votar
mientras que en los suburbios de
afluencia blanca lograron votar sin
ningún problema y estoy hablando de las
primarias en este verano pues yo creo
que es una clara señal y el presidente
lamentablemente también está jugando a
ese juego de querer hacer una división
digamos de clases porque en sus tuits
han mencionado que él aprobó una ley que
le impide a las personas de bajos
recursos vivir en los suburbios porque
eso incita a la violencia yo creo que no
se puede decir que el presidente
realmente está a favor del pueblo cuando
hace ese tipo de declaraciones que
indudablemente tienen también no
solamente un corte clasista sino de
cierta manera un corte racista
lamentablemente el presidente yo creo
que haría un mejor trabajo si decidiera
en señalar cómo podría mejorar la vida
de los hispanos y de los afroamericanos
ahora que se está hablando de que han
perdido sus empleos y que no tienen un
sistema de salud fuerte porque esa es
otra de las cosas que también ha
planteado el presidente de querer
desmantelar el obama que dice que por
una orden ejecutiva le va a permitir a
esas personas que tienen condiciones
preexistentes mantén eso seguro cuando
eso ya está establecido precisamente por
obama que yo creo que me parece a mí más
honesto
el presidente entablar a un plan más
concreto para recuperar la economía
dentro de esos grupos que han sido mayor
frente afectados y que según las
encuestas no lo favorecen ni los
afroamericanos y los latinos por lo
menos si no si nos remitimos a las
encuestas
robert gracias por su opinión y quiero
ir a la misma ciudad donde se encuentra
la silla de nueva york pero con nuestra
corresponsal
mamen salam amén la oposición demócrata
citó a declarar al señor luís de joel
fue designado por el presidente o en el
trump como el director general del
servicio postal de ese país el señor de
joy aceptó ir al congreso a declarar la
próxima semana y le preguntó qué esperar
de esta declaración del señor de yo y en
el medio de la polémica por estos votos
por correo donde él preside
asegura que es un vehículo para que se
cometa el fraude donde los demócratas
pues están denunciando todo tipo de
trabas por parte del presidente donald
trump para que estos votos a lo mejor
nunca lleguen o lleguen después de
muchos días luego de la votación del 3
de noviembre
sí pues va a ser una declaración desde
luego muy esperada y como todo lo que
estamos viendo en mitad de esta pandemia
vamos a ver cómo se desarrolla lo que
está claro es que el presidente don al
drama al final está consiguiendo un
poquito lo que esperaba que al final era
robar esa atención de la convención
demócrata y es interesante también raúl
que acabamos de escuchar a la senadora
catherine cortes y ella va a ser la
única interventor a la única persona
latina que intervenga en todos los
discursos que vamos a escuchar esta
noche algo que yo creo que el partido
demócrata en este sentido lo ha dejado
un poquito atrás el voto latino
interesante también que ha sido la
primera vez que han mencionado esa
colecta de fondos porque al final al fin
y al cabo no olvidemos que este congreso
virtual tiene como objetivo la
recaudación de fondos para la campaña y
que va a ser muy difícil llevar a cabo
esta labor sobre todo teniendo en cuenta
que la mayoría de eventos van a ser de
manera virtual entonces pues bueno como
todo lo que estamos viendo en esta
inusual convención y en estos inusuales
días de pandemia
vamos a ver qué es lo que nos depara no
ahora mamen también quiero volver un
poco con la declaración del republicano
john cage y el ex gobernador del estado
de ohio porque le quiero preguntar hacia
dónde quiere apuntar esta campaña para
la presidencia de joe biden con esta
declaración del ex gobernador
republicano que votos quiere captar con
esta declaración de john cage ik
sí yo creo que está muy claro cuál ha
sido la estrategia del partido demócrata
en este caso que es un poco lo que ya
sabemos y es que donald trump con la
gestión que ha hecho de esta crisis
sanitaria y con la situación económica
en la que nos encontramos pues ha dejado
un poco de lado al país y eso es lo que
quieren mostrar los demócratas no
solamente ha dejado de lado a la
población estadounidense sino que su
propio partido le da la vuelta en su
propio partido le da la espalda y
también hay divisiones dentro de su
propio partido además no debemos olvidar
que según las últimas encuestas va a ir
en no solamente va por delante del
presidente de donald trump sino que
además también está rascando votantes de
los votantes indecisos que hasta ahora
la mayoría en la mayoría de ocasiones
siempre apostaban por los republicanos
en el último momento y parece que
empiezan a inclinarse cada vez más por
los demócratas yo creo que con esta
intervención ha sido un intento de
mostrar por un lado la división que
ellos también tienen dentro de su
partido más allá de la que puedan tener
los demócratas dentro del suyo que hemos
visto en estas primarias y a lo largo de
estos meses pero bueno quieren hacer
también hincapié
trump tiene también ovejas negras dentro
de su partido y por otro lado
reivindicar la mala gestión que ha hecho
durante esta pandemia y la situación
económica a la que nos ha conducido
también gracias ahora quiero ir con la
señora lyon arda turan desde la ciudad
de miami ella es analista política y
está estratega demócrata señora durán
con estos millones de personas
desempleadas en el país a cuenta de la
pandemia de coronavirus hacia donde se
van a ir estos votos de estas personas
desempleadas
mira yo creo que lo hemos visto lo hemos
visto desde que comenzó no solamente la
pandemia sino su presidencia es
discúlpame porque tuvimos problemas
técnicos antes no me han podido expresar
no se preocupe mucho lo que decían pero
él dijo quién era él dijo quién era
cuando bajó de las escalinatas con un
discurso totalmente racista nos dijo lo
que pensaba de los hispanos sé que a mí
no me sorprende absolutamente nada el
hecho de que él quiera a sabotear el
derecho que tenemos todos constitucional
de votar por correo es una falta de
seguridad la misma falta de seguridad de
él como líder que sabe que ha perdido
tanto camino inclusive dentro de su
mismo partido el gobernador kasich de
ohio
está en un movimiento que se llama never
trump nunca trump porque porque los
republicanos que eran republicanos de
centro quizás
no se sienten no se reflejan en lo que
el presidente de donald trump estaba
haciendo entonces si él no quiere que le
cuenten los votos es porque él ha visto
las encuestas
en la última de cnn el tener el
vicepresidente joe biden tenía un 51 y
él tenía un 46 y otras encuestas lo dan
perdedor también con respecto al nazismo
si yo llegué a este país un día de
febrero de 1987 y los eeuu en el que
vivo hoy no es la misma nación no es la
misma nación que conocí cuando llegué
la división que hay en este país es algo
inimaginable en este país que debió ser
el bit con la de la libertad este país
que debió ser siempre en la cabeza del
mundo especialmente en estas cosas que
pasan como la pandemia se ha convertido
en la cola del mundo no sé cómo pueden
defender la gestión de trump pero no sé
a qué vota qué tipo de votante es el él
está apelando porque su 33 por ciento de
base a como digo a esa señorita que su
padre murió por hacerle caso a lo que
decía el presidente trump el presidente
trump nunca creyó en el copyright y el
presidente trump salía
a darlos a los briefings de salud
conjunto con la doctora berta en la y el
doctor fauci sin usar mascarilla
líder que se respete y que esté para la
responsabilidad de una pandemia donde la
vida de los ciudadanos de los eeuu está
a riesgo hizo todo lo contrario las
señales que él mandó fue para que el
virus se convirtiera en lo que es hoy la
doctora pérez que una de las personas
que trabajaba con él decía que ella
esperaba que el virus el covenant y
tuviera el mismo resultado en eeuu que
tuvo en italia pero ella tuvo que
admitir su propia persona
la médico encargada del cobi nineteen
tuvo que admitir hoy que él combina en
team se le fue de las manos y se le fue
de las manos por la falta de interés de
trump porque a trump no le interesamos
los eeuu trump es un narcisista lo único
que él quiere es quedar bien ante las
cámaras quien le que les siga nosotros
decimos yo soy de origen dominicano que
le siguen limpiando el polvo y que sigan
la gente desconociendo lo que él ha
hecho en este país pues no está latina
sabe lo que él ha hecho con el racismo
porque está latina ha visto cómo se
discriminan por ejemplo yo vivo en un
área donde hay una ciudad que se llama
homestead donde los trabajadores de la
los farmers los las personas que
cultivan los campesinos en el centro
número uno el centro más caliente de
covina porque además yo soy médico y
nadie hace caso a eso las estadísticas
no sé de dónde tampoco en la florida que
voy a hablar aquí el que vivo de donde
la saca el gobernador no sé de dónde
saca sus números no entiendo cómo dicen
que los números han mejorado cuando
nosotros mismos sabemos que no es cierto
y cómo está aumentando el claro tienen
que hacer más test y si no hacen más
test no van a dar los números que son
ciertos y hasta es
él ha mandado a parar o sea él está
poniendo a la población estadounidense
en peligro de muerte y lo digo muy
responsablemente porque cuando un líder
un líder no se lleva ni siquiera de los
de su propio del cdc no se lleva de
ninguna institución médica de este país
porque él cree que lo sabe todo él está
poniendo en riesgo la vida de todos los
ciudadanos norteamericanos y esto la
historia se lo va a cobrar a donald
trump señora mccowan quiero ir con usted
desde la ciudad de washington del otro
lado la bancada la bancada republicana
gracias por su intervención señora durán
quiero retomar también un poco de lo que
hablábamos para tocar todos los temas
sobre el voto por correo que el
presidente de una nación rechaza y los
republicanos demócratas quieren que vaya
adelante además los demócratas quieren
aprobar la legislación que prohíba hacer
el cambio
este sistema postal antes de las
elecciones le pregunto señora mccowan si
esta será la nueva batalla política en
washington antes de estas elecciones del
3 de noviembre
bueno va a haber muchas batallas
políticas como siempre lo ha habido en
la historia de los eeuu especialmente
antes de las elecciones por razones
obvias realmente no se necesita un
experto es más fácil cometer fraude con
del voto ha sido por por correo que
cuando el voto es personal cuando usted
va a votar
qué pena interrumpir la voy con él pero
ni sandro se están organizando si ha
vuelto con un 7 adelante compensando los
100 años y el peor colapso económico
desde la gran depresión que estamos
enfrentando el racismo sistémico y la
amenaza a nuestro planeta a través del
cambio climático y en medio de todo esto
ya tenemos un presidente que no
solamente es incapaz de enfrentar estas
crisis sino que nos está llevando por el
camino del autoritarismo esta elección
es la más importante en la historia
moderna de este país en respuesta a las
crisis sin precedentes que enfrentamos
necesitamos unas respuestas sin
precedentes
movimiento como nunca antes de personas
que estén preparadas para levantarse y
para luchar por la democracia y la
decencia y en contra de la oligarquía
y la intolerancia necesitamos yo parecen
como nuestro próximo presidente déjenme
tomar esta oportunidad para decir algo a
las millones de personas que apoyaron mi
campaña este año y también en el año
2016 amigos muchas gracias por su
confianza por su apoyo y por el amor que
me mostraron a mí a jane ya mi familia y
juntos hemos hecho avanzar este país
en una nueva dirección mostrando que
todos nosotros los afroamericanos los
latinos los blancos los nativos los
saris ya ticos los homosexuales y los
que no lo son
quieren una nación basada en los
principios de la justicia del amor y la
compasión nuestra campaña se terminó
hace ya varios meses
pero nuestro movimiento continúa y se
está haciendo cada vez más fuerte muchas
de las ideas que ahora parecemos
luchados que sólo hace unos años se
consideraban radicales ahora son comunes
pero déjenme ser claros y donaldson es
reelecto todo el progreso que hemos
alcanzado quedará dañado y esta elección
se trata de preservar y preservar
nuestra democracia durante este
presidente durante esa presidencia lo
impensable se ha vuelto normal él ha
tratado de evitar que la gente vote ha
tratado de socavar al sistema postal al
desplegado a los agentes federales en
contra de manifestantes pacíficos ha
amenazado con retrasar la elección y ha
sugerido que no se irá de la oficina si
se en si pierdes
esto no es normal y nunca debemos
tratarlo como si fuera normal bajo esta
administración el autoritarismo ha
tomado raíz en nuestro país mi familia y
yo y muchos de ustedes saben lo que
puede hacer el autoritarismo para
destruir la democracia la decencia y la
humanidad mientras que yo esté aquí
trabajaré con los progresistas con los
moderados y si también con los
conservadores para preservar y evitar
que esta nación sucumba ante esta
amenaza ya que tantas personas lucharon
y murieron por defender esos principios
es no solamente una amenaza para la
democracia sino que al rechazar la
ciencia ha puesto nuestras vidas y
nuestra salud en peligro chop ha atacado
a los doctores a los científicos
a aquellos que han tratado de
protegernos de la pareja y ha evitado
tomar una acción fuerte para producir
las máscaras y los guantes y todo lo
demás que tanto necesitan las personas
que nos atienden mientras la casa se
quema con juega al golf
sus acciones han resultado en más de
170.000 muertes y en una nación que aún
no está preparada para proteger a su
gente además la negligencia de sión ha
exacerbado la crisis económica que ahora
estamos experimentando desde que comenzó
esta pandemia más de 30 millones de
personas han perdido sus empleos y
muchos han perdido su seguro de salud
muchos familias trabajadoras se están
preguntando cómo van a darle de comer a
sus hijos y se preocupan de que puedan
ser sacados de sus hogares y cómo ha
respondido 8 en lugar de mantener
con el apoyo de desempleo de 600 dólares
semanales y los cheques de 1200 dólares
de emergencia que muchos recibieron en
lugar de ayudar a los pequeños negocios
creó órdenes de ejecutivos fraudulentas
que básicamente no hacen nada para
atender esta crisis mientras que al
mismo tiempo amenaza el futuro de la
seguridad social y medicare pero la
verdad es que incluso antes de la
respuesta negligente de champ a la
pandemia
muchas personas trabajadores muchas
familias ya estaban en un ya no tenían
esperanza de poder salir adelante
juntos debemos construir una nación que
sea más equitativa más compasiva
y que incluye a todos se que joe biden
comenzará esa lucha desde el primer día
déjeme ofrecerle unos cuantos ejemplos
de cómo yo by the nos va a llevarse
adiós joe biden apoya el aumento del
salario mínimo 15 dólares por hora esto
le dará a 40 millones de trabajadores un
aumento y levantará esa escala para
todos los demás para que sea más fácil
que la gente se puede unir los
sindicatos creando 12 semanas de sanidad
paga y hará que el servicio para los
niños sea asequible para muchos se va a
reconstruir nuestra infraestructura y a
enfrentar la crisis el cambio climático
llevándonos a una transición hacia 100
por ciento de energía limpia en los
próximos 15 años estas iniciativas van a
crear millones de buenos empleos que
pagan bien en todo el país
como ustedes saben somos la única nación
industrializada que no garantiza la
salud para todos sus habitantes mientras
que joe y yo no estamos de acuerdo en la
mejor manera o el mejor camino para
llegar a una cobertura universal él si
tiene un plan que va a expandir de gran
manera el cuidado de salud el servicio
de salud y a recortar el costo de los
medicamentos va a reducir la edad para
ser elegible para medicare de 65 a 60
para ayudar a reformar nuestro sistema
criminal que está roto él va a acabar
con los centros de detención privados y
el camino que lleva de la escuela
directamente a las prisiones él va a
acabar con el odio y con la división que
camps ha creado él va a detener las a
transición de inmigrantes el culto a los
blancos nacionalistas
la intolerancia y los ataques a las
mujeres queridos amigos les digo ustedes
y a todos aquellos que apoyaron a otros
candidatos en la primaria y a todos
aquellos que tal vez hayan votado por
donald trump en la última lección el
futuro de nuestra democracia está en
juego el futuro de nuestra economía está
en juego el futuro de nuestro planeta
está en juego tenemos que unirnos y
derrotar a la nación y elegir a joe
biden y a kamala harris como nuestro
próximo presidente y vicepresidente
queridos amigos es el precio de fallar o
simplemente es demasiado grande para
imaginar gracias
ahí lo tenían ustedes el discurso en
esta convención demócrata de senador por
el estado de vermont bernie sanders
además fue ex aspirante presidencial
para estas elecciones y para las
elecciones pasadas quiero volver
entonces con la señora a maricruz
mccowan ella es estratega republicana
que antes de esta intervención del
senador sandro estábamos conversando con
ella sobre el voto por correo que además
fue uno de los puntos que tocó escenario
sandro si quiero que cerremos esa idea y
comentar un poco y brevemente lo que
dijo el senador sanders para entonces
darle paso a los otros invitados y
estamos pendientes a la intervención de
la ex primera dama michelle obama
adelante señora ma cowan bueno como
decía el voto por correo no tiene los
parámetros de cuidados de prevención que
tiene el voto personal cuando uno va a
un recinto y observadores de ambos
partidos o sea lo que se trata de
prevenir es que una persona vote dos
veces que haya personas que no deberían
votar como personas que no son
americanas usando los nombres de muertos
que sean
miles de casos y personas que no tienen
18 ante él será que no se cometa el
fraude eso se puede prevenir cuando
alguien va a votar persona persona por
lo menos en la media de los casos
cuchillo no vota por código eso puede
evitar
respecto al discurso del de bernie
sanders me extraña porque no es eso lo
que él decía en las primarias de haydn
lo atacaba en muchos sentidos de lo que
yo estoy diciendo de jubail en el habla
de que tiene un plan para unificar el
tiene un plan para todo porque ocultó
ese plan que podía haber beneficiando a
los americanos por más de 45 años si lo
hubiera implementado
vamos con la intervención de michelle
obama y vuelvo con usted
y todo el mundo lo siente de manera
distinta dice que muchos de ustedes
en este momento y yo lo comprendo
pero estoy aquí esta noche porque amo a
este país con todo mi corazón y me duele
ver a tantas personas
atravesando el dolor he conocido a
tantos de ustedes he escuchado sus
historias y a través de ustedes
he visto la promesa de este país y
gracias a todos aquellos que vinieron
antes de mí gracias a su sangre y su
sudor yo he podido vivir esa promesa
esa es la historia de eeuu
todas esas personas que se han
sacrificado y superaron tanto en sus
propios tiempos porque querían algo más
algo mejor para sus hijos
hay mucha belleza en esa historia hay
mucho dolor en ella también
mucho la lucha injusticia y aún queda
trabajo por hacer
quienes podemos como presidente en esta
elección va a determinar si o no o no
éramos honramos esa lucha
y mantenemos vivo viva la posibilidad de
continuar con ese trabajo y de
terminarlo yo soy uno de las personas
que vive hoy que ha visto de primera
mano el peso y el gran poder de la
presidencia
y déjenme decirles esto
el trabajo es difícil requiere un juicio
claro poder mantener
una devoción de la historia y un con una
guía moral y una habilidad para escuchar
y también una creencia firme en que cada
uno de las más de trescientas millones
de vidas en este país tiene un sentido y
valor los valores de un presidente
pueden mover mercados pueden comenzar
guerras o crear paz pueden reunir a
nuestros mejores ángulos o despertar
nuestros peores instintos simplemente no
pueden hacer las cosas de esta manera
ser presidente no cambia quién es
realmente
revela quién eres
bueno una elección presidencial puede
revelar quiénes somos nosotros también y
hace cuatro años muchas personas
decidieron creer que sus votos no
importaban
tal vez ya estaban cansados estaban
hartos pensaban que el resultado no
sería tan cercano o que la colina era
demasiado impide empinada pero al final
esas elecciones llevaron a alguien a la
oficina oval que perdió el voto popular
por cerca de 3 millones de votos en uno
de los estados que determinó el
resultado el margen de victoria el
promedio era de 2 votos por presidente 2
votos y todos hemos estado viviendo con
esas consecuencias cuando mi esposo se
fue lo que si no van con yo baiden a su
lado teníamos una creación récords de
empleos habíamos asegurado el derecho a
la salud para 20 millones de personas
está éramos respetados en el mundo
uniendo a nuestros aliados para
enfrentar al cambio
y nuestros líderes se habían trabajado
de la mano con los científicos para
ayudar a evitar un brote de ébola y
evitar que se convirtiera en una
pandemia global cuatro años después el
estado de esta nación es muy diferente
más de 170 mil personas han muerto
nuestra economía está en graves
problemas por un virus que este
presidente ignoro por mucho tiempo ha
dejado a millones sin empleo muchos han
perdido su salud su protección de salud
y no han podido proteger sus necesidades
básicas como la renta o la comida muchas
comunidades se han quedado pensando cómo
poder volver a abrir las escuelas de
manera segura y de manera internacional
le hemos dado la espalda no solamente a
los acuerdos que forjó mi esposo sino en
las alianzas que fueron lideradas por
reagan o aysén house y aquí en casa
como mientras george freudiana tyler y
una lista sinfín de personas de color
inocente siguen siendo asesinados es
decir que las vidas negras importan y
sigue siendo ignorado desde la casa
blanca porque cuando miramos a la casa
blanca por liderazgo o por consuelo o
buscamos en ella
firmeza y liderazgo lo que obtenemos es
caos división y una falta absoluta de
empatía y empatía eso es algo en lo cual
yo he estado pensando mucho últimamente
la habilidad de ponerse los zapatos de
alguien más reconocer que la experiencia
de alguien más tiene valor también la
mayoría de nosotros lo hacemos sin
pensarlo si vemos a alguien sufriendo o
en problemas no nos ponemos a juzgar
vamos a ayudar porque por la gracia de
dios' verse no si no es un concepto
difícil de comprender es lo que le
enseñamos a nuestros hijos y como tantos
de ustedes para que yo hemos tratado o
hemos dado lo mejor para instaurar en
nuestras hijas una base moral para que
cuiden los valores que nuestros padres y
nuestros abuelos nos pusieron a nosotros
pero ahora los niños en este país están
viendo lo que ocurre cuando dejamos de
pedir empatía unos con otros están
mirando a su alrededor preguntándonos si
vamos y les hemos estado mintiendo todo
este tiempo sobre quiénes somos y lo que
realmente valoramos vemos personas
gritando que no porque no quieren
ponerse una máscara algo que nos
mantendría seguros a todos ven personas
llamando a la policía por personas que
no están haciendo nada simplemente por
el color de su piel si ven algo que dice
que solamente algunas personas
pertenecen aquí que la avaricia es algo
bueno y que ganar es cual es todo porque
a medida que ganes no importa lo que le
ocurra a los demás y ven lo que ocurre
cuando esa falta de empatía entra y ven
como nuestros líderes están llamando a
otros enemigos del estado
cuando apoyan a los supremacistas
blancos ven como separan a los niños de
sus familias y los ponen en jaulas y
lanzan gases lacrimógenos en contra de
manifestantes simplemente para poder
tomarse una foto tristemente ese es eeuu
que queda ahora para la próxima
generación una nación que no solamente
se está quedando atrás en términos de
política sino en términos de carácter y
eso no sólo es decepcionante sino que es
algo que no se enfurece porque yo sé y
conozco a la bondad y la gracia que está
allá afuera en los hogares en los
barrios en todo este país y comprendo y
sé que sin importar nuestra raza nuestra
religión o nuestras visiones políticas
cuando cerramos y dejamos de lado ese
ruido y el miedo y realmente abrimos
nuestros corazones
y sabemos que lo que está ocurriendo en
este país simplemente no está bien no
queremos hacer esto entonces qué hacemos
ahora cuál es nuestra estrategia en los
últimos cuatro años muchas personas me
han preguntado cuando otros van y caen
tan bajo
ir arriba todavía funciona mi respuesta
es ir arriba es lo único que funciona
porque cuando nosotros bajamos cuando
nosotros caemos y utilizamos esas mismas
tácticas de degradar y satanizar a otros
nos hacemos parte de ese sonido que
acaba con todo lo demás nos degradamos a
nosotros degradamos las causas por las
cuales luchamos pero seamos claros subir
no significa sonreír y decir cosas
lindas cuando estamos enfrentándonos a
la crueldad y la maldad subir significa
tomar el camino difícil significa
buscar nuestra manera para subir por esa
montaña subir significa enfrentarnos a
lo divino recordando al tiempo que somos
una sola nación ante dios y que si
queremos sobrevivir tenemos que
encontrar la manera de vivir juntos y
trabajar juntos a pesar de las
diferencias y subir también significa
acabar con las mentiras y la falta de
confianza con lo único que realmente
puede llevarnos a la libertad y eso es
la pura verdad entonces déjeme ser tan
honesta como pueda hacerlo
donald trump es el presidente equivocado
para este país ya ha tenido suficiente
tiempo para probar que puede con el
trabajo y claramente no puede
no puede enfrentarse este momento
simplemente no puede ser lo que nosotros
necesitamos que él sea para nosotros es
lo que es ahora comprendo que mi mensaje
no será escuchado por algunas personas
vivimos en una nación que está
profundamente de mi vida y yo soy una
mujer afroamericana hablando en una
convención demócrata pero muchos de
ustedes ya me conocen lo suficiente
saben que yo les digo exactamente lo que
estoy sintiendo saben que odio la
política pero también saben que me
importa esta nación y saben que tanto me
importa nuestros hijos entonces si toman
algo de estas palabras esta noche es
esto si creen que las cosas no pueden
empeorar confíen en mí si pueden y se
harán si no logramos un cambio en esta
elección y si tenemos alguna esperanza
de acabar con este caos tenemos que
votar por joe biden como si nuestras
vidas dependiera de ello
yo conozco al joe él es un hombre
profundamente desempeño guiado por la fe
y fue un vicepresidente increíble él
sabe lo que significa rescatar una
economía derrotar una pandemia y liderar
a este país y él escucha él dirá la
verdad y confiara en la ciencia para
planes inteligentes y manejará un buen
equipo y también va a gobernar como
alguien que ha vivido una vida que
nosotros podemos reconocer cuando él era
niño
el padre de joe perdió su empleo cuando
era un senador perdió a su esposa y a su
pequeña hija y cuando era vicepresidente
perdió a su querido hijo entonces joe
sabe la angustia de sentarse en una mesa
con una silla vacía enfrente y es por
eso que ofrece su tiempo de manera
gratuita a tantos padres que atraviesan
dolor por eso ofrece su ser
número de teléfono a niños que están
superando sus problemas con el
tartamudeo su vida es un testamento a
volver a levantarse y él va a llevar esa
pasión para levantarnos a todos para
ayudarnos a sanar y para guiarnos hacia
el futuro joe por supuesto no es
perfecto y él sería el primero en
decirlo pero no existe un candidato
perfecto no existe un presidente
perfecto y su habilidad de aprender y
crecer podemos encontrar ahí el tipo de
humildad y el tipo de madurez que tantos
de nosotros queremos tanto y deseamos en
este momento porque joe biden ha servido
esta nación a toda su vida sin nunca
antes haber perdido
de vista quién es él pero más que eso él
nunca ha perdido de vista quiénes somos
nosotros todos nosotros
joe biden quiere que todos nosotros
vayamos a una buena escuela que podamos
ir al médico que vivamos en un planeta
saludable y él tiene planes para hacer
que eso ocurra joe biden quiere que
todos nuestros hijos sin importar cómo
se vean puedan salir por su puerta sin
preocuparse de ser perseguidos
arrestados o asesinados
él quiere que todos nuestros hijos
puedan ir a una película o una clase de
matemáticas sin tener miedo de recibir
un disparo quiere que todos nuestros
hijos puedan crecer con líderes que no
solamente van a servir a los suyos y a
sus amigos multimillonarios sino creando
una red de seguridad para las personas
que atraviesan dificultades y si tenemos
una oportunidad de perseguir estos
objetivos cualquiera de estos
requerimientos básicos para una sociedad
que funcione tenemos que votar por joe
biden
con cifras que no puedan ser ignoradas
porque justo ahora las personas que
saben que no pueden ganar de manera
justa están haciendo todo lo que pueden
para evitar que votemos están cerrando
centros de votación en barrios de
minorías están acabando con reglas de
votación están sacando a y están
intimidando y están mintiendo sobre la
seguridad de estos votos estas tácticas
no son nuevas pero este no es el momento
para evitar votar a manera de protesta o
evitar votar por candidatos que no
tienen oportunidad de ganar tenemos que
votar como hicimos en 2008 y 2012
tenemos que mostrarnos ahí con el mismo
nivel de pasión y de esperanza
tenemos que votar de manera temprana en
persona si podemos hacerlo tenemos que
pedir un nuestro voto
esta misma noche para que lo envíen
inmediatamente y hacer el seguimiento de
asegurarse que lo hayan recibido y
asegurarse que los familiares y amigos
hagan lo mismo tenemos que salir con
nuestra máscara y tal vez con algo de
comida porque tenemos que estar
dispuestos a estar ahí en una fila toda
una noche si es necesario ya hemos
sacrificado tanto este año y tantos de
ustedes ya están yendo y sacando extra y
tienen un corazón imaginable para darle
a nuestros seres queridos una
oportunidad de continuar con su vida y a
pesar de la ansiedad están entregando
sus paquetes están llenando numerosos
supermercados para que nosotros podamos
seguir avanzando incluso cuando todo
esto se siente tan abrumador los padres
trabajadores de alguna manera están
logrando lo que los profesores se están
volviendo creativos para que los niños
puedan seguir creciendo y aprendiendo
los jóvenes están desesperados siguiendo
sus sueños
y ante este racismo sistémico que crea
un shock en nuestra conciencia millones
de estadounidenses de toda edad de todo
pasado de todo origen se levantaron para
marchar por el otro pidiendo justicia y
clamando por el progreso esto es lo que
todavía seguimos siendo personas llenas
de compasión la resiliencia personas
decentes cuyas fortunas y cuyos destinos
están unidos unos con los otros heart es
tiempo que nuestros líderes de nuevo
reflejen nuestras verdades entonces
nos corresponde a nosotros unir nuestras
voces y nuestros votos al curso de la
historia haciendo eco de los héroes como
jon wish que dijo cuando ustedes ven
algo que no está bien
deben decir algo y deben hacer algo esa
es la mayor forma de empatía no
solamente el sentimiento sino el hacer
no solamente para nosotros o para
nuestros hijos sino para todos para
todos nuestros niños y si queremos
mantener la posibilidad del progreso
viva en nuestro tiempo si queremos ser
capaces de mirar a nuestros hijos en los
ojos después de la adicción tenemos que
retomar nuestro lugar en la historia
estadounidense y hacer todo lo que
podamos para elegir a mi amigo joe biden
como el próximo presidente de los eeuu
gracias a todos que dios los bendiga
ahí la tenían ustedes entonces era el
discurso de la ex primera dama michelle
obama la más esperada de la noche en
este primer día de convención demócrata
en eeuu y ahora si quiere volver
entonces con la señora maricruz mccaw en
ese gran estratega republicana
economista y vocera del comité nacional
republicano señora macagua envuelve con
usted y ya entonces para ir cerrando
este especial de noticias quiero saber
su opinión de toda esta esta convención
y recibir un poco entonces qué le
parecieron los últimos discursos que
vimos antes de tener que interrumpirla
por la señora michelle obama tiene usted
la palabra señora mccowan bueno el
discurso de la ex primera dama que voy a
tener mucho cuidado porque yo creo que
todas las primeras damas deben recibir
el un respeto especial y quisiera que
también la señora turan recibiera ese
tipo de respeto de nuestros colegas
demócratas que han desafortunadamente no
lo tiene
a mí me parece muy bien que ya hablará
de que la gente fuera a votar en persona
pero al mismo tiempo dice la cndh en su
voto ahora mismo lo cual desde iu se irá
a votar en persona y más bien apoya el
rumor pongámoslo porque este momento es
el rumor de que el señor tide en el ex
vicepresidente biden no quiere debatir
al señal presente trump y que prefiere
que la gente vote antes de que él tenga
la oportunidad que no debata al
presidente camps yo creo que hay que
esperar por los debates y yo me quedaría
en eso y una nota no ellos han estado
como en el poder los señores obama el
presidente obama y su esposa por ocho
años en la casa blanca yo creo que han
tenido una situación envidiable para
arreglar en lo que llama el problema
racial sistémico que según ella es parte
del sistema que yo estoy en desacuerdo
con eso no hay eso
no te sistémico yo no sé cómo es posible
que después de ocho años el racismo
antes del presidente obama estaba un
nivel después de que el término después
de ocho años no mejoró el problema de
racismo y ahora quieren hacernos creer
que al día siguiente que salió de
presidente el racismo subió en forma
exponencial no es verdad también me voy
a hablando continuando con el racismo la
señora durán dicen llegado en 1987 no
había racismo eso no es verdad y ha
llegado a los estados unidos en 1982 en
noviembre del 82 y en ese tiempo ni
siquiera no podía hablar español en
público porque así de fuerte del racismo
igual en los trabajos y en todas partes
era abierto los insultos era de cara a
cara que ahora no se puede decir todo se
hace con cobros obama con baile en
control ha mejorado en cierta manera y
una vista personalmente ya nadie se
atrevería a decir me voy a tratarme
ahora como me trataban en 1982 a mí a
cualquier hispano ha mejorado y eso hay
que reconocerlo señora más joven gracias
por su opinión y quiero ir entonces
ahora con nuestra corresponsal en la
misma ciudad en washington de la capital
estadounidense diana para resumir un
poco lo que vimos esta noche en este
primer día de la convención el demócrata
estadounidense y que viene que podemos
esperar para los próximos días
bueno hay que resaltar que un tema en
común durante las diversas
presentaciones de los líderes demócratas
de los líderes del partido que respaldan
a baile de las personas que dieron sus
testimonios y ciudadanos fue la llamada
a la unidad a salir a votar a mostrarse
en las urnas ya fuera por correo o en
persona y es precisamente lo que la
primera dama ex primera dama quería
destacar en este discurso de cierre y lo
que vimos también por parte del senador
bernie sanders de vermont donde llamaba
a esa unidad y es que el senador bernie
sanders pues logró crear un movimiento
muy grande en donde movilizó a los
votantes latinos a los votantes jóvenes
y también a muchas tiene el respaldo de
muchas uniones laborales en el país de
trabajadores así que por esta razón es
que el propio partido demócrata está
enviando un llamado a la unidad pero
también para que los miembros de este
partido los demócratas salgan
por bailén y esto marca la diferencia
con lo que ocurrió en las elecciones
pasadas cuando muchas personas del
movimiento de bernie sanders no apoyaron
a hillary clinton así que este es un
mensaje claro que se ha visto durante
esta primera jornada de lo que es la
convención del partido demócrata mañana
tendremos una transmisión similar en
directo a través de las redes sociales
en donde se esperan más testimonios
donde estará hablando una de las
personas centrales del movimiento joven
del partido demócrata que es la
representante
alexandra ocasio por nueva york también
estará hablando del ex presidente bill
clinton el miércoles estará hablando los
presidentes obama y hillary clinton
kamala harris hablará y se espera que
también ya el último día del cierre
hable
el delegado encargado de llevar a cabo
esta convención pero también cierre con
su discurso
joe biden y se haga ya oficial su
candidatura entonces se espera una
jornada muy amplia durante toda la
semana y también se espera que el
partido decida las reglas de lo que será
no solamente las reglas de las próximas
elecciones como elegirán en estos
comicios internos a su candidato sino
también cuál será la plataforma que
tendrá el partido demócrata de cara a
estas elecciones y será una plataforma
progresista como veíamos a sanders
hablando de acceso al cuidado del salud
para todos incrementar el salario mínimo
a 15 dólares por hora así que hay que
ver también no sólo cuál será el
discurso de joe biden sino también
cuáles serán esos aspectos que lograrán
negociar al imperio de la convención los
miembros del partido demócrata así es
diana gracias entonces por acompañarnos
en este especial de noticias y por
supuesto nos veremos durante todos estos
días hasta el
el jueves el día final de esta
convención demócrata gracias por su
tiempo que tenga usted una muy buena
noche y quiero ver que nuestra otra
corresponsal en la ciudad de nueva york
mamen sala mamen hablemos entonces un
poco de los discursos que escuchamos de
el senador bernie sanders que defendió
esta candidatura y también defendió a
perón y sandro es lo que no vimos a lo
mejor en su momento con hillary clinton
cuando ya fue candidata en el año 2016 y
también el llamado de la de la ex
primera dama michelle obama diciendo los
ciudadanos que voten como sus vidas como
si sus vidas dependiera de eso y de
hecho el collar de ella decía boat mamen
si la verdad que ha sido muy interesante
coincido con mi compañera diana en la
unidad que se ha mostrado en este primer
día de convención algo que no estaba muy
claro porque sí que hemos visto durante
estos meses que había una serie de
divisiones dentro del partido muy
potente muy poderoso el discurso de
bernie sanders un discurso de apoyo al
que haya sido su contrincante en estas
primarias y por el que habían peleado
ambos bastante
incluso mucho más fuerte como decías de
lo que vimos defender a hillary clinton
en el 2016 interesante también que
bernie sanders ha tenido ese momento
para despedirse como candidato que no
tuvo por la pandemia porque pasó un
poquito descafeinado el triunfo de joe
biden no debemos olvidar que bernie
sanders llega muy fuerte a esta
convención llegaba con más de 1100
delegados es decir con un gran
electorado que le apoya y al final pues
bueno estas son las masas esa es la
población que él tiene que atraer para
que apoyen a joe biden muy interesante
también ha sido el discurso de michelle
obama creo que ha sido una buena
combinación después de un discurso más
político que podría ser el de el ex
candidato yo
bernie sanders con un discurso más
social más íntimo que desde luego habría
sido imposible en un en un gran espacio
con aplausos y confeti y al uso ha sido
un discurso íntimo cercano en el que se
ha hecho mucho hincapié a la empatía no
ha sido una palabra que hemos escuchado
mucho durante esta
durante este primer día interesante
también ese collar que llevaba con las
letras boat porque ese era su gran
objetivo invitar a la gente a animarla a
votar incluso ha escenificado como
debería ser ese voto lleven sus
bocadillos abriguen se ha muy
interesante también pero sobre todo ha
sido bonito raúl ha sido bonito ver como
todos los demócratas cierran filas y se
unen con joe biden que desde mi punto de
vista
no es el candidato más fuerte para
luchar contra donald trump pero creo que
ha sabido rodearse de un equipo potente
que puede darle unas posibilidades de
ganar sobre todo con la última con la
recién nombrada candidata a la
vicepresidencia
kamala harris y como decía mi compañera
diana en washington escucharemos su
discurso de manera remota también este
miércoles y ya el jueves pues joe biden
recibirá esa nominación de manera formal
para ya acabar esta convención demócrata
tan inusual
e histórica de manera completamente
virtual así es mamen gracias también por
estar con nosotros en este especial
todavía nos quedan tres días para seguir
hablando de los demócratas hacia dónde
van qué podemos esperar en los próximos
días gracias a mamen sal a nuestra
corresponsal en nueva york' y me quedé
en esa ciudad para saludar nuevamente a
robert valència analista político
internacional robert quiero saber su
opinión acerca de este primer día de
convención demócrata un poco resumiendo
lo que vimos esta noche que podemos
esperar
bueno yo creo que el primer el primer
día de la convención es un más bien un
llamado a las emociones al sentido de
unidad no tanto en el aspecto de
política y de una propuesta en el plano
político en el plano de trabajo en la
presidencia de sí yo creo que eso es lo
que lo que hemos visto es decir es un
llamado al despertar a la conciencia del
estadounidense de ver que la situación
en eeuu pues no es fácil realmente hay
que decirlo y lamentablemente se ha
polarizado más todavía en la vida
nacional y están haciendo ese llamado a
la unidad y el de resarcir a algunas
heridas abiertas yo quiero hacer un
señalamiento porque me parece que es
importante que nosotros como medios de
comunicación no demos pie a la
desinformación lo que dijo la invitada
anterior era que el voto por correo es
fraudulento eso es mentira y yo creo que
ya ese tema que claudicar lo de una
buena vez por todas porque yo creo que
nosotros no podemos
al juego de donald trump de la
distracción de la desinformación
entiendo que el presidente es el
presidente y lo que dice tiene
consecuencias serias pero cuando él ha
anunciado más de 100 veces que hay
fraude electoral por medio del correo
sin mostrar ninguna evidencia pues yo
creo que ahí es donde tiene que parar el
tema el el voto por correo se ha venido
ejerciendo desde hace más de 150 años y
los mismos oficiales los mismos
funcionan los funcionarios electorales
lo han dicho que es imposible que haya
un fraude así que yo espero que ese tema
quede total
porque ya el tiempo nos apremia pero yo
creo que aquí lo más importante es ver
cómo en los próximos días los demócratas
van a abordar temas tan importantes para
los hispanos como por ejemplo el sistema
de educación donde lamentablemente el
presidente de trump ha hecho uso de la
política de su política para amenazar a
los distritos escolares de que si no
abren las escuelas pues él va a retener
fondos que aunque él no lo puede hacer
eso solamente lo puede hacer el congreso
pues obviamente si el congreso sigue
esas indicaciones del presidente de
donald trump eso afectaría a los
estudiantes de bajos recursos
empezando por los hispanos y por los
afroamericanos hay que ver qué plan
tiene yo bailé en el aspecto de la
educación igual en el tema de la sanidad
el presidente de donaldson se ha
empeñado en atacar
obama que en vez de mejorar lo que
obviamente requiere mejoras pero ha
amenazado a lo largo del tiempo de
desmantelar de revocar una ley que de
cierta manera ha beneficiado a un
a un parte una parte de la población el
tema de la inmigración también es otro
de los temas importantes lamentablemente
el presidente
donald trump como lo mencionó la
invitada de miami inició su campaña
política atacando a los mexicanos
diciéndole que eran unos
narcotraficantes violadores etcétera
amenazó digamos está empeñado en la
construcción del muro que no lo ha
completado ha hecho renovaciones
renovaciones del muro pero no ha
completado el muro y tampoco y mucho
menos ha forzado méxico a pagarlo con
vuelo como fue su promesa de campaña
también trató de derrocar el daca que es
el la acción diferida para aquellas
personas aquellos jóvenes que llegaron
muy niños a este país y que son de
documentados y que todavía tienen esa
oportunidad de trabajar a través de daca
y él lo que hizo es mantener a también
el tema de la de la vivienda si es otro
importante en fin son muchos temas que
yo espero que esos éstos sean abordados
y bueno también va a quedar un lunar en
esta convención del hecho de que no esté
julián castro que es una
las latinas más prominentes de los
demócratas yo creo que eso también va a
ser un tema de discusión en los próximos
días y desde la ciudad de nueva york
bajamos un poco en el mapa de eeuu para
ir a la ciudad de miami con leonardo
durán leonard a un resumen de lo que
para usted fue este primer día de
convención demócrata
bueno fue maravilloso yo en el 2016 en
julio del 2016 tuve la oportunidad de
participar en la convención como
delegada de la candidata a hillary
clinton y la emoción que uno siente es
indescriptible pero ver que el partido
el partido demócrata está haciendo lo
correcto a mí me llena de mucho orgullo
el partido demócrata está más unido que
nunca lo demuestra el discurso de berni
sanz la cndh es la parte más progresista
del partido demócrata pero también lo
demuestra el discurso de la ex primera
dama michelle obama nosotros nosotros
esta generación tiene la responsabilidad
de seguir la historia de este país no de
devolvernos para atrás nosotros tenemos
que seguir avanzando en la democracia y
quiero terminar diciendo una frase a mis
queridos
con ciudadanos republicanos que yo sé
que hay muchos de ellos que se han
arrepentido porque hablo con ellos se
han arrepentido de haber votado por
donald trump pero a la señora
maricruz yo quiero decir una frase del
presidente republicano a abraham lincoln
donde él decía
del mismo modo que yo no quiero ser un
esclavo tampoco quiero ser un amo y eso
es lo que define la democracia
imagínense así es que salir a votar
voten por correo porque es legal cuiden
su voto salga porque de nosotros depende
el futuro del pueblo americano y del
mundo porque este país tiene que volver
a ser lo que era
era grande antes de donald trump señora
marca one voy a la ciudad de washington
en la capital estadounidense para
conocer su última opinión en este
especial de noticias
bueno me gustó mucho cómo terminó la
señora durán con el eslogan del
presidente trump make américa great
también pegamos los eeuu grandes de
nuevo estoy totalmente de acuerdo con
ella en ese sentido y bueno hablando de
que si no deberíamos ser ambos de
esclavos y nos entonces porque lo apoya
a apoyar discurso de bernie sanders
donde venden y sanders públicamente es
un admirador y nueva negado de la
administración de fidel castro- terminar
me admiro lo que ya la educación en cuba
que realmente indoctrinación y pregunten
a cualquier cubano especialmente a los
que arriesgaron sus vidas en una balsa
para llegar a los estados unidos si el
gobierno de fidel castro no era
autoritario y violento entonces no es
posible decir una cosa y actuar de otra
manera hay que ser consecuente y ante
todo hay que poner américa primero
es lo más importante y como decía
también el señor que las elecciones por
correo ha sido comprobado por expertos
eso tampoco es verdad porque no hay
expertos que hayan comprobado eso no han
comprobado nada y si yo estoy muy fuerte
en que debe haber debates primero entre
el presidente trump y el vicepresidente
biden para que la gente vea dónde está
la fuerza dónde están las ideas donde
está el dinamismo y que luego se vote y
se vote personalmente sí sí los
demócratas pueden ir a protestar si
pueden incentivar el incendio y matar a
las personas porque hacerlo mucho de
georges void pero no hablan aquí está el
muchachito de cinco años canon y final
de lorca o vaina que un afroamericano le
dé un tiro y lo mató tampoco hablan de
personal un afroamericano que tenía una
señal que decía que ella la apoyaba a
donald trump también nader en un tiro
no escucho las protestas de eso porque
una vida la vida de un niño no tiene
ningún valor porque la vida de otro
afroamericano no tiene ningún valor o
sea sólo las minorías que apoyan al
partido demócrata tienen valor pero si
no apoyan al partido demócrata no tienen
valor eso es absurdo y se debe acabar
con esa hipocresía máxima yo creo que el
pueblo americano va a ver después de los
debates porque tiene que haber debates
por quién quiere votar se quiere tener
las promesas la utopía que habla siempre
el marxismo pero que no haga nada o de
ver como sus vidas nunca estuvieron tan
bien como estuvieron con el presente
trump y acusan al presidente trump de
todos los males de los eeuu por sus tres
años y medio de presidencia y no decir
nada del express vicepresidente biden
por sus más de 45 años de vida política
eso también me parece absurdo y estoy
segura que este noviembre la gente va a
saber qué es lo mejor para ellos
y lo común de los american para
prevalecer señor valencia no sé si tiene
alguna opinión al respecto ya brevemente
para finalizar el especial de noticia y
poder despedirlos a todos ustedes cuando
sí totalmente acuerdo vamos a esperar a
ver lo que veían electorado yo creo que
ya no vale la pena darle vueltas al
mismo asunto
en un experto
si tenemos un poco unos problemas de
comunicación con el señor valencia en la
ciudad de nueva york dio nada no sé si
tiene algo que aportar le pido que se
apruebe de un minuto minuto y medio por
su respuesta para finalizar el especial
pero yo creo que la señora maricruz
sigue la misma táctica del presidente de
donald trump que es a mandar mensajes
erróneos sin ninguna prueba yo creo que
los norteamericanos los americanos
nosotros los ciudadanos americanos que
vivimos en este país sí que vamos a ser
inteligente porque tres años y medio fue
suficiente para todos nosotros blancos
negros e hispanos latinos europeos a que
no tenemos en ese respeto en europa que
teníamos antes vamos ya vimos que era
donald trump y vamos a votar porque yo
no dije que américa era grande con
donald trump yo dije que hay que volver
a hacer américa de rande como lo era
antes de la américa que hizo donald
trump bueno buena noche señora durán
gracias por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en este especial de noticias en
france 24
no se acabó el tiempo porque aquí nos
pudiéramos seguir quedando pero el
tiempo en televisión ya es corto quiero
agradecer entonces a la señora leonardo
durán week analista política y
estratégica demócrata desde la ciudad de
miami también a maricruz mccowan
estratega republicana economista y
vocera del comité nacional republicano y
el único hombre invitado a este especial
de noticias será robert valència
analista político internacional que nos
atendió muy amablemente desde la ciudad
de nueva york y entonces hasta aquí
llegamos a desde este especiales de
noticias analizando un poco lo que fue
este primer día de convención demócrata
que va hasta el día jueves 20 de agosto
y por supuesto los quiero invitar a que
nos sintonicen siempre a las 20 horas a
bogotá quito lima para estos especiales
de noticia vamos a estar cubriendo esta
convención demócrata 24 días es por
supuesto la semana que viene la semana
entrante también haremos lo mismo
haremos lo correspondiente con la
convención republicana hasta aquí este
especial de noticias para mí fue un
placer estar con ustedes estas dos horas
y media de información hasta
[Música]